[Musique]
tous ont de quoi tu me parles tu rigoles
ou quoi la radio journaux tout le monde
enfin à le truc mais oui ce matin celle
au pressing méga tschudi sabah nous est
la bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez les quais voici
lendemain fille
c'est bien laurent bonsoir bonsoir
sortait de l'émission de clémence arnaud
oui génial cette marée top
non mais je lui ai demandé à ma femme
qu'elle laquelle enregistre ouais c'est
des fois sur le plateau on ne saisit pas
tout on est content de revoir les choses
coincent et passer une bonne soirée déjà
excellentes
c'est là ça va continuer alors on est au
top et je pense qu'on est au top c'est
une soirée france 2 ouais on est au top
alors on bat toujours à la fiche de sexe
magouille et culture générale 1
alors je sais que vous avez du mal à
faire les petites mains souffle quand
ses pensées pour moi alors allongé à
deux fois
voilà donc c'est au théâtre du gymnase
alors 2 laurent baffie avec laurent
baffie
j'en ai ras-le-bol des salles toutes les
semaines avec pascal sellem mado maurin
daniel russo géraldine bonnet guérin et
je voulais dire à nos amis
téléspectateurs d'arrêter d'aller voir
cette pièce parce que laurent est
fatigué il y en a marre il trouver
l'emplacement donc il faut absolument
arrêter parce que si ma fille est trop
fatigué il sera incapable de bouger
pendant le jingle et ça sera bien
dommage
j
alors un email un email de bertrand
richelieu de maubeuge qui dit cibafi
bouge pas pendant le jingle il aura
droit à un baiser d'une fille du public
j'aurais public de la dernière fois
à
[Musique]
mise à part laurent baffie je recevrai
ce soir ronald j
[Applaudissements]
médéric des grèves et ouais
eva herzigova
bing et rothschild
serge july
et frédérique bedos jean philippe lafont
[Musique]
pour arbitrer le blind test un blind
test consacré ce soir au cinéma en
hommage au festival de cannes
j'accueille magie à philippe corti
à
messieurs mai
ce soir
alors un email de jean-philippe frau de
bourg saint maurice
il avait parié 500 balles que cortier
entrerait par la droite et quartier est
entré par la gauche
donc il a perdu le mec voulait payer sa
redevance avec ça continue à nous
regarder
c'est mal barré
[Musique]
et maintenant comme chaque semaine les
meilleurs moments de l'émission
précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par jean yves noël
mesdames messieurs magnéto serge est ce
que vous allez vous marier
nous vous êtes dans votre maison dans le
midi tous assez calme ses eaux
pourquoi passer ou fait mais ça c'est
pas ma route pour tunis au caire où le
procès robert est ce qu'on a envie
qu'ils viennent vous avez la foi vanessa
oui je crois en dieu je crois que tout
le bordel qu'il ya dans le monde il n'a
pas été créé par dieu les bons mais je
vais peut-être raison vous savez je
souhaite nous erekat à la fois c'est
bien veilleux parce qu'on se dit bah je
vais aller aussi à elle mais personne
n'est jamais revenu il ya des milliards
de cadavre et personne ne revient pas
devient suspect il n'a pas été nous
couper la parole
ça fait deux soeurs qui vient rien
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce qu'ils n'avaient plus
d'intérêt pour beaucoup sur moi parce
que je suis très fan de galawa donc
j'écoute ma femme mais ça va est ce que
vous êtes gros lolos gros lot est ce que
vous êtes
repro rocco et ses frères encore que ces
frais d un rocco siffredi rocco siffredi
way qui connaissait pas rocco siffredi
non c'est un type qui est monté comme un
âne
allons allons non non non j'ai pas de
détails vous dire mais c'est pas rocco
ses parts au coccyx poko assez pour
cause c'est pas un conseil à
communication qui vous conseille sur
votre coupe de cheveux vous me direz non
non ce qu'on dit plus tôt c'est que
c'est pas vraiment le look qu'il
faudrait mais ça m'est égal c'est celui
qui me plaît rédacteur vous êtes un
verre intègre et comptent dépenser des
fonds pour faire face
votre film préféré parmi tout ce que
vous avez fait est le film le plus nul
que vous ayez fait rebeus moi ce n'est
pas terminée tant vous parler de la
vraie raison des écoutes téléphoniques
il fallait à tout prix justifié
l'existence de la cellule des barbouzes
de l'elysée qui n'avait aucune raison
d'être
et pour cela et bien il fallait faire
croire que françois mitterrand était
menacée et ils ont monté un faux
attentat
et c'est cette histoire que je raconte
encore un le deuxième
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors si on m'avait dit un jour que gala
vous exposerai tout le monde là il peut
se répéter
j'étais souvent apparu le best of de la
semaine précédent
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est ronaldinho
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toujours
là
on a vu mieux 1 messieurs bonsoir très
heureux de vous avoir avec nous ce soir
vous avez 21 ans vous êtes une super
star du foot au brésil 14 sélections
dans l'équipe du brésil
bientôt superstar en europe puisque vous
avez signé avec psg pour pour cinq ans
on dit que vous êtes plus fort que
ronaldo c'est vrai non non j'ai commencé
depuis peu et ronaldo c'est un joueur
confirmé et que j'ai depuis longtemps
on vous a appelés et ronaldinho parce
que vous n'êtes pas si épais que ça
finalement vous faites un mètre 78 71 kg
petit ronaldo ronaldinho est ce que tu
es be alors changes depuis
nos petits gambo petites dents en avant
là c'est très joli tout les brésiliennes
sont folles de vous à cause de ces deux
petites banques dépassent un peu là bon
c'est calme il ya des positions qui
m'aime me suive recherché calme alors
votre vrai nom c ronaldo des assisses
moreira on vous appelle ronaldo gaucho
parce que vous venez de porto allègre
qui est la région où il ya des gauchos
qui s'occupe du bétail dans la campagne
vous êtes né dans une favela une famille
passionnée de football
votre père était soudeur dans un arsenal
mais en plus il s'occupait des voitures
sur le parking du club de foot gremio à
porto allègre et votre frère votre frère
c'est roberto assis ce qui est un grand
joueur effectivement roberto tellement
grands joueurs que pour le garder le
club de porto allègre le gremio avait
offert une villa avec une piscine au
père de ronaldo et de roberto et votre
père est mort quand vous aviez huit ans
d'hydrocution il est tombé dans la
piscine il est mort d'hydrocution
exactement comment ça s'est terminé
moi j'étais jeune à l'époque mais elle
est décédée dans une piscine mais je ne
sais pas dans quelles circonstances vous
à 18 ans est votre premier cadeau ça a
été un ballon et des chaussures de foot
et vous avez appelé à dribbler contre
les meubles du salon
c'est exact oui je jouais beaucoup quand
j'étais jeune j'ai beaucoup avec mon
chien
alors vous êtes devenu célèbre en
quelques secondes en 1999 dans un match
qui opposait le brésil au venezuela
votre premier match dans la seleçao vous
entrez en deuxième mi-temps et raconter
ce qui s'est passé comment vous êtes
devenu une star en un match si je peux
m'acheter pas encore quand même apprécié
les gens me connaissaient même os brisés
connu l'europe
quand il est venu grâce à ce bon mon jeu
dans ce dans ce match magnéto rose rbq
notaire rêver du caf ou cogiter
quant au fait vous passez à me
connaissez pas vos votes
mais
et
tu sais
c'est fou
c'est bon
je t'ai aimée
à fait
[Musique]
à
on était vaste monde
avec une hôtesse pas villa sise à mika
blason et chaumont pas rejoindre ses
potes du barreau vos portes à coude à
coude
[Musique]
ok
bakar hadji cap o
janssen
[Musique]
c'est acquis
je sais
alors très tôt dont vous êtes devenu une
star en 2000 j'avais 20 ans et le club
anglais de leeds vous offre 500 millions
la même année
milan ac vous propose 48 millions de
francs par an et le gremio fait une
contre-proposition 1 900 mille francs
par mois
est ce que quand on a 20 ans quel effet
ça fait de devoir qu'ont vos esprits la
fifa la dure d'aborder ces questions
d'argent
moi je ne pense pas l'argent je pense
simplement aider ma famille et toutes
mes pensées se tournent vers le jeu je
ne pense pas à l'argent parce que
l'argent c'est quelque chose de
compliqué sûr que je suis quoi l'argent
je n'ai pas bien joué
donc c'est un jeu qui m'intéresse alors
vous refuser toutes ses propositions
parce que finalement vous êtes séduits
par l'idée de venir jouer à paris et
donc le 12 janvier 2001 une radio sport
fm annonce votre signature de contrats
le psg dément et le parisien à ce qu'on
l'a fait sa une avec marc est le sauveur
puisque évidemment comme vous le savez
on a besoin de joueurs de foot chez les
mecs on a besoin de mecs qui bouge
pendant le jingle alors il ya eu quand
même des réactions assez négative au
brésil à l'idée de vous perdre les gens
de porto allègre sont très tristes avait
des goûts parti j'ai joué longtemps au
gremio temps dans mon club et ses gants
donc j'ai fait un climat de confiance
avec eux c'était même famille et donc
quand j'ai parti j'ai apporté ma famille
j'ai été triste mais maintenant j'ai un
nouveau nouvelles à venir une nouvelle
vie oui ils ont quand même mis sur la
pelouse du stade à porto allègre ils ont
quand même mis des sacs avec des faux
billets à l'intérieur avec marqué dessus
c'est pas très sympa quand il est parti
c'est le traducteur il va revenir
je m'attendais à cela je devais temps
des décisions est j'ai pris la bonne
décision parce que je veux évoluer en
tant que joueur et en tant que personne
et paris c'est le bon endroit afin que
je me développe harmonieusement débat du
personnel il ya un truc un peu étrange
quand même ronaldinho c'est que vous
avez choisi de venir au psg à cause de
la bonne réputation du psg au brésil une
réputation professionnelle même dans le
monde entier à pêcher tout ça c'est un
grand club une bonne saison mais tout le
monde sait que c'est un très grand club
ce que peu évolué positivement dans la
prochaine période
oui il ya eu beaucoup de brésiliens qui
ont joué au psg et ricardo il ya eu
valdo et leonardo rails
vous êtes le 12e brésilien a porté les
couleurs de la capitale alors le contrat
est toujours pas signé pour le moment
n'ont pas encore je n'ai pas signé de
contrat mais je vais venir certainement
jouissive messieurs des problèmes
toujours avec le club de porto avec qui
veut pas vous laisser partir
gratuitement
non il ya une négociation entre le psg
et lyon et lorsqu'ils auront trouvé un
accord bon la situation sera résolue
mon niveau vous connaissez paris non
c'est la première fois que vous venez à
part pardon je connaissais rien de ça je
viens pour connaître cette ville je
cherche un nouveau domicile et
connaissent rien qui rit oui on va vous
on va vous sortir on va vous donner un
endroit super tour eiffel
marc et chouilly bien sûr s'est assuré
de jouer au football après mais c'est
pas grave en même temps mise à part le
fait qu'on vous a collé trois rôles à la
coupe du monde
non nous avons mise à part la victoire
de la france sur le brésil en coupe du
monde pour quelque chose
vous savez quoi du foot français on à
l'union je connais quasiment actuelle je
suis le football français je vois
français qui je trouve très bien tant
pis si dan anelka est un joueur en
france si tu es bon je chanterai pas dit
si oui pourquoi l'équipe de france est
devenue la meilleure équipe du monde à
votre avis
devant le brésil ont eu beaucoup de
chance
oui ils ont mérité cette victoire
j'ai recommencé brésilien mais j'espère
que la prochaine fois nous vaincrons en
janvier de cette année 2001 vous ai fait
un match à six contre six dans un jardin
de buenos aires s avec maradona
vous adorez maradona vous l'avais
tellement dévorer des yeux pendant le
match qui était un match amical bien
entendu que vous avez perdu
et à la fin il a dit maradona a dit en
parlant de ronaldinho je voulais une
fois dans ma vie jouer contre toi car tu
le dernier qui me fait rêver dans le
football a beaucoup
cela m'a beaucoup touché
c'était un moment très spécial que je
n'oublierai jamais non non les candidats
disent elles étaient défoncés aussi donc
les pendules à l'heure alors au brésil
vous avez jamais afficher votre argent
vous de vous relier dans une fiat tipo
au brésil est ce que à paris avec un
salaire important si vous allez avoir
quand même
1.5 millions de francs par mois + 10
millions de fois en prime de signature
est ce que vous allez garder votre fiat
tipo oui mais ici il va falloir trouver
une autre voiture une bonne voiture dans
laquelle je puisse me déplacer bien
est-ce que vous avez choisi paris parce
que vous êtes toujours célibataire oui
ici un coup de jolies femmes au
magnifique tant que célibataire bon je
suis prêt à faire des rencontres et
peut-être je me marierai qu'une
française a alors vous voulez lancer un
appel vous disiez en référé mois grande
amitié brésil a juste d'arriver ici en
france
pour l'instant je suis heureux c'est bon
je suis prêt à faire des rencontres vous
profitez de votre tranquilité un petit
peu absent pognon sordo
dès ce soir après au psg et maintenant
voici la vie nocturne
[Musique]
alors je vous dis tout de suite bonsoir
madame au phare messier parce que je
sais que je n'ai pas beaucoup quand on
dit bonsoir nom alors je vous le dis
aussi on doit pas dire bonsoir on dire
bonsoir madame
et puis ce fut bien sûr d'apprendre
plein de choses voilà fort madame ça le
rend si vous pouviez essayer d'éviter
les hoquets leccia tout ça parce que la
baronne aime pas trop quoi
mais ça va de soi l'argent n'est diana
si je dis bien se tenir
ne vous inquiétez pas on va parler de
votre livre qui s'appelle l'amour est
une affaire de femmes chez robert
laffont
vous savez comment c'est un
c'est votre c'est votre septième livre
recueille quant à psa est là pour ça
sans briller la première fois que
quelqu'un vous appelle avant de passer
avec libre on va parler
[Applaudissements]
l'un parcours absolument incroyable et
nenad in l'hôpital y et ruag apte à
puteaux votre mère était ouvrière votre
père inconnu et votre beau-père et des
gardiens de la paix vous viviez dans un
petit deux pièces obscur l'eau il
fallait chercher dans la cour et votre
ciel évasion c'était la lecture et vous
aviez trouvé un livre poussiéreux dans
un placard au fond d'un vieux placard
c'était le savoir vivre écrit par la
marquise louise d'alc et quand vous
lisiez ce livre vous aviez l'impression
de présider des dîners somptueux où des
hommes en habit s'incliner devant des
femmes s'incliner jusqu'à terre vous
imaginez en lisant ce bouquin il vit
entouré de lys et de roses
et puis quand vous ouvriez les yeux vous
reveniez dans votre petit deux-pièces de
puteaux et c'est là c'est là qu'est née
votre toute cette ambition de s'en
sortir
oui mais à vous entendre j'ai
l'impression que c'est les misérables
j'ai l'air de causette dans votre un peu
l'impression non pas vite nous écouter
dans le quartier tout le monde était
comme moi donc il y avait pas de raison
que je sois plus plus pauvres que les
autres risques les autres on était tous
à la même un fouet alors votre premier
amour s'appelait georges truchot oui
voilà c'est un fils de chiffonniers qui
il allait vous cherchez des fleurs dans
les poubelles c'est très beau cette
histoire très belle histoire
et lorsque c'était pas terrible quand
vous étiez petite enquête le 10 mai les
taches de rousseur dont on apprécie de
faire j'ai changé si vous les fait avant
lui ce serait bien mais vous saviez déjà
séduire traite ou vous avez compris oui
j'ai appris très vite
c'est quoi votre secret je crois que
c'est la gaieté je vais vous dire il
n'ya pas un homme qui résiste à la gaîté
d'une femme à la gentillesse la gaieté
un peu de perversion bien entendu ce
mois
elle est comme vous ma femme c'est vrai
elle est réglée très enjoué comme ça le
matin en se réveillant puis la
perversion aussi
bien alors j'ai commencé à travailler à
l'âge de 14 ans chennai bailleur donc
c'est deus de voiture et vous dit dès
que j'ai eu le certif je suis parti de
chez moi donc pour travailler mais quand
j'ai été nommé docteur honoris causa de
l'université de jérusalem
vous avez déclaré pas mal pour quelqu'un
qui n'a pas son certif
oui c'est vrai je n'ai jamais eu un
budget déjà mais enfin il fallait bien
qu'un jour je dis c'est lorsque je
voulais travailler que je l'avais cibray
d'accord voilà mais très courageuse dire
que pour arrondir vos fins de mois vous
nettoyez les escaliers d'immeubles où
vous habitiez non mais là c'était très
jeune pour arrondir ses fins de mois
c'est dans la bio ensuite vous travaillé
dans une fabrique de laine vous mettez
des pilotes dans des sacs
vous avez quand même une première vie
qui était pas drôle du tout non son père
les misérables
il ya des tas de femmes qui sont comme
moi aujourd'hui et elles vont pas nous
mais c'était absolument patrie je vous
assure alors beaucoup d'ambitions un
très jeune vous dites je préférais
rester chez moi que sortie mal
accompagné oui et c'est normal je vais
vous dire quand vous voulez réussir dans
la vie il ya des tas d'hommes autour de
vous et tas de gens qui vous sollicite
pour pour être avec vous parce que vous
êtes mignonne vous avez 16 ans bon moi
je préférais rester chez moi que d'être
mal accompagné mais la compagnie ça veut
dire par un homme qui pouvait rien nous
apporter enfin exactement vidéo et j'ai
deviné
là j'arrive à la fiche numéro 69 vous
connaissez le principe
c'est vous qui me poser une question
barone les rôles sont inversés
évidemment pour une fois c'est bien en
tant que femme de banquier je voudrais
savoir si vous avez un compte non
déclaré dans une banque étrangère
alors voilà la question c'est bien ça me
permet de bien nous disent oui et non on
avait les avis on n'est jamais bien quoi
poser non je sais pas faire ça paye mes
impôts et que ma cheville ne suis pas
fort la demande alors beaucoup
d'ambition et on peut dire pas une
grosse vertus non plus n'ont écouté tout
dépend ce que c'est que ce qu'est ce que
vous appelez que la vertu est ce que
c'est un homme deux hommes trois hommes
qu'est ce que c'est oui bon il ya des
limites quelque part bon je n'ai pas
vous dire exactement si j'étais
vertueuse ou pas j'étais une jeune fille
de mon temps je crois qu'aujourd'hui
elles se valent un jour vous tombez sur
le peintre jean gabriel domergue
vous avez rendez vous avec une amie qui
voulait poser pour lui et en fait l'idée
qu'il vous voit il vous dit vous
commencé le matin absolument et je vais
vous dire c'était la soeur d'elisabeth
tessier
j'ai travaillé avec moi et qui mettait
les pelotes de laine dans les sacs
c'est parce qu'elle est devenue
d'ailleurs et voilà et donc à saison
finalement vous commencé à poser pour
jean gabriel domergue devient long cou
comme ça un petit nez en trompette très
parisienne comme les parisiennes donné
qu'ils rasent 1 et à leur première
séance de poses humiliation vous aviez
oublié de vous laver les cheveux comment
une fille comme vous rend la couille ces
tournois écoutez ça peut arriver nul
n'est parfait
elle nous a renvoyés chez vous et vous a
dit il ya toujours du savant dans une
maison exactement la renvoyer chez vous
vous installez vous l'avez les jeux où
s'est produit c'est une très bonne leçon
je veux dire je n'ai jamais saillir là
ce soir c'est bien alors domergue et de
niveaux de pygmalion et alors là vous
avez connu un peu le tout paris puisque
anna de noailles par exemple donné aux
séances de pause est rentré dans le
milieu parisien grâce à ça non oui enfin
rentrer dans le milieu parisien je
voulais entrer dans le milieu du théâtre
parisien sur elle alors de modèles et de
meneuse de revue
comédienne lisons d'une certaine façon
même si vous êtes très humble par
rapport à vos talents de comédienne vous
ai fait beaucoup de films beaucoup de
pièces mûri j'ai beaucoup travaillé en
angleterre j'ai tout fait surtout
beaucoup de comédies musicales
et puis j'ai fait l'olympia j'ai fait la
bcge effet les capucines
ouais et voilà comment ici vous avez
commencé sur les planches à 17 ans avec
francis lopez et après ça je sais pas
c'est vous qui doublait martine carol
dans caroline chérie c'est qu'elle soit
devenue le tir d'egli hornu oui quoi je
voulais pas un centime car on veut bien
mais si on peut et qui vous doublent
maintenant pour le samedi j'avais
présenté les premiers bikini en tournée
mondiale aux étés speakerine à l'olympia
oui et à cette époque que vous
rencontrez brassens et alors il était
fou d'amour de vous et vous vous
intéressez pas du tout faut pas exagérer
fou d'amour non mais enfin il était
charmant mais comme je vous l ai dit
tout à l'heure il faut savoir dire non
en quelques fois oui alors il a écrit ça
pour vous grâce à ce joli fleurs balance
[Musique]
savais pas qu'il s'agissait tout en
entendant cette chanson parce que c'est
moi qui vous inviter à dîner vous lui
disiez non demain quoi c'était la
tactique pour le fer ferreux vinea bien
sûr j'ai pas assez d'argent
c'est pas qu'il avait pas assez d'argent
c'est que ce n'était pas mon genre donne
d'une part et puis et puis j'avais
d'autres ambitions c'est quoi ça c'était
pas brassens a alors au cinéma vous
faites des rôles secondaires dans des
séries b vous étiez un peu le numéro
deux derrière bardot à une époque non
oui j'ai travaillé avec bar de huy et
les critiques disait xavier légende
spirituel et vous étiez une ingénue
perverse et reste un terme plus
tellement ingénue berbère s'est terminée
aujourd'hui d'abord je suis passé je ne
sais même pas s'il y en a encore et vous
allez hollywood
et vous refusez hollywood vous refuser
un contrat de sept ans hollywood
pourquoi parce que d'abord je veux dire
je ne suis pas quelqu'un que l'on peut
mettre dans une cage
donc là c'était vraiment une très belle
cage dorée mais qui ne me convenait pas
et puis resté sept ans dans un endroit
où vraiment je n'avais aucun contrôle
non je préférais il fallait vous faire
peroxydée les cheveux avoir un fiancé
officiel à effet blonde comme marilyn
monroe c'était pas mon style et tout le
monde devait être comme elle
et voilà on vous dit j'ai compris que je
ne serai jamais une grande star j'avais
pas le physique et si je voulais
franchir une nouvelle étape
ce ne pouvait être que par le mariage
c'était le but si vous voulez que je
m'était imposé c'est de trouver un mari
pas forcément puissante non seulement
riche et qu'on reste immensément riches
ils étaient des limites toujours non non
je réponds épousé un je ne peux pas vous
dire moi un prix nobel
quelqu'un qui a fait vraiment le pouvoir
j'aime le pouvoir alors la richesse et
la puissance effectivement vous fasciner
et vous dites avec pas mal d'humour
d'ailleurs dit ya toujours des femmes
qui tombe toujours sur le plombier moi
chaque fois que je vais vérifier venu
vers moi c'est la vérité mais je vous
dis on ne sait pas pourquoi les hommes
riches attire certaines femmes pourquoi
est ce que les hommes sont attirés par
des femmes comme moi j'ai un bon
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que si on fait la
cour circulaire n a pas d'autre d'abord
parce qu'on a la même vie
mais mme way of life on connaît les
mêmes gens c'est plus facile pour être
sûr non c'était quand même la ruée vers
l'or non je dirais plutôt que c'était la
ruée vers le diamant vous quittera way
et là vous tombez sur edmond de
rothschild donc dans un dîner en 1960
vous dites la beauté d'un homme ça m'a
jamais vraiment compté pour moi
non non et je trouve que ça n'a aucune
importance à guingamp ce jour peut-être
ouais ouais avant de passer à table soit
vous rencontrez dandiner il vous dit
vous portez un beau diamant dommage
qu'ils soient faux et c'était vrai jeu
c'est vrai et c'était vrai après vous
retrouvée assise à côté de lui il avait
une boîte boîte à pilules où il y avait
une alliance caché et vous livre votre
alliance est sûrement vrai mais c'est
pas sûr qu'elle soit sa place c'est
normal quand on est marié je sais pas où
il à vos fins si un lecteur doit pardon
en principe c'est là où elle doit être
sans que vous vous les doigts et leur
centre jean mais attendez ça veut dire
qu'il enlevait son alliance pour aller
sans sa femme dans l'es10 nerfs
exactement vous avez tout compris
jamais ça vous ne seriez jamais seul non
alors il ya un problème c'est qu'elles
demanderont s'il venait de se marier
alors c'est difficile de faire divorcer
un homme un homme marié depuis trois ans
n'ont écouté c'est pas moi qui lui ai
demandé le divorce je pense que le
couple ne devait pas très bien marché et
puis et puis voilà c'est ce qu'on
appelle le coup de foudre nous le
premier soir le premier soir quand vous
êtes vu ça a été la vague versailles
je peux dire que j'ai été très séduite
oui le coup de foudre non ouais non
simplement c'est pour les emails qui
m'ont bien est-ce que vous avez coucher
le premier soir c'est agréable
c'est une question qu'on va avoir
beaucoup sur moi non mais je sais que
j'ai répondu que non mais je sais que
c'est important je crois qu'il faut
faire l'averse voyez-vous monsieur
bachus il faut toujours cyr atteindre un
homme quand même temps vous l'avez fait
attendre l'heure et demie non non non
non non non non non non je crois qu'il a
dû attendre moins de moi oui deux mois
je partais aussi en tournée alors c'est
pour ça et vous vous êtes resté pendant
trois ans dans l'ombre d'une certaine
façon vous l'avez laissé marier avec
cette femme
et vous vous attendiez enfin vous étiez
pas mal vous avez acheté un appartement
la muette quand même ce que tel de dire
pour pâques alors quatre pièces et la
bulle est sympa oui mais en fait j'avais
autre chose avant faut pas exagérer
quand même
oui exactement je toujours les rues
thématique de jeu alors il finit par
divorcer 1
j'ai bien pris là et alors problème
c'est qu'il vous dit je peux pas je peux
pas t'épouser parce que tu n'es pas
juive
oui mais vous qu'à cela ne tienne
miracle vous êtes enceinte
oui j'attends mon fils c'est le flux de
nom mais ça tombait bien disons vraiment
ça tombe bien non écoutez un enfant ça
ce programme cet homme n'avait pas
d'enfant il voulait un enfant nous avons
fait un enfant est bien peu devant le
fait accompli non non pas du tout là
haut la ola pas du tout cher monsieur
alors ça vous vous trompez qu'on peut me
dire moi je vous pose parce que non mais
vous me posez la question je vous
réponds non
cet homme voulait être un enfant il
s'est dit voilà une ficelle je vais
faire un enfant mais bon donc il était
alité au courant ah oui vaut mieux marié
en catastrophe en robe de chambre à
l'hôpital parce que vous étiez quand
même on s'expose ans marié chez moi pas
l'hôpital attention je suis mariée chez
moi en robe de chambre c'est vrai
puisque j'étais couché j'attendais mon
fils et là vous vous convertissez au
judaïsme et vous êtes accepté par la
famille ça a été difficile pour vous de
d'apprendre le talmud et tout ça pas du
tout absolument pas à partir du moment
où vous êtes vous êtes capable de tout
enregistrer et d'être une bonne élève
gelé
j'ai été convertie par le grand rabbin
qu'un plan kaplan qui a été un homme est
absolument extraordinaire et j'ai passé
je dois dire 2 à me convertir et
maintenant donc vous êtes de religion
juive
c'est le nom moi j'en ai canapé
convertible du slam et alors vous dit en
parlant de ça d'ailleurs en parlant du
fait que les rothschild a accepté une
fille qui venait quand même d'un milieu
très modeste vous dites je me demande si
les marchés les époux marché aurait
voulu d'un rothschild comme jambre je ne
le crois pas bon c'est vrai qu'on sait
qu'il doit taxer
sûrement pas ouais bien que bien que je
vais vous dire quand rothschild a paraît
il ya plus de yap religion il ya plus de
frontières je pense que oui c'est
dommage il que si monsieur marché avait
il avait eu une fille jeu en définitive
je crois qu'il aurait accepté alors ils
n'avaient pas bon caractère à monsieur
le baron quand même a dit oh la la soupe
au lait c'est vrai vous disent ils en
auraient fait fuir plus d'une
il est macho le baron et j'aime les
hommes machos fait un homme comme les
hommes doivent l'être quand même laissé
le terminal est ce que la liste eh bah
terminale ont maintenant été match ya
des matches où étaient les gaullistes et
mais comme tous les amarres on est
exigeant oui les coureurs ça
écoutez moi je connais pas d'hommes qui
ne soit pas coureurs c'est vrai vous
dites là la fidélité masculine n'existe
pas à mes yeux ça n'existe pas
il en faisait cette phrase merveilleuse
que je voudrais que toutes les femmes de
france écoute aimer un homme c'est
accepter de le voir heureux avec une
autre que vous
[Applaudissements]
ça me change de isabelle alonso c'est
sur la générosité cissé mais
profondément quelqu'un beaucoup de
femmes vous dise ah j'adore mon mari
j'adore mon mari si tu le laisses
tellement laisse le vivre sa vie si vous
aviez été sa maîtresse pendant trois ans
avant qu'ils vous épouser donc malgré
tout vous saviez qu'il avait des
maîtresses puisque et vous pas rendre de
votre côté vous pratiquez aussi le je
n'ai jamais lu de vous quelque part mais
attendez non donc il faut avant tout
être discrète
alors c'est vrai que quand vous parlez
de vous vous comparez souvent une geisha
voir une esclave ou dit la femme est
fait pour plaire et écouter ça me paraît
normal quand on nommera entre de 2,2 du
bureau qu'il a envie de vous parler
la moindre des choses est de l'écouter
tout pour éviter le divorce c'est à dire
que vous n'êtes pas tout accepter plutôt
qu'un divorce
oui parce que vous dites il vaut mieux
être trompé que divorcé ça demande moins
de formalités
exactement c'est très cynique mais quand
on voit les désastres si vous voulez de
ses enfants d'occasions ouais moi ça me
rend malade
tous ces jeunes qui se marient et quatre
ans après qui force c'est pas les
enfants qui sont l'occasion les bosses
dans les mains des enfants sont des
enfants d'occasions pour le prochain si
vous prenez la dame vous prenez les
gosses avec bon et si vous prenez les
gosses avec c'est vraiment on voulait on
voulait présenter des objets d accepter
sont des enfants d'occasions je suis
désolé je m'endorme mais non non moi non
plus je n'aime pas mais c'est la vie qui
est comme ça
bon et si les gens faisaient un tout
petit peu plus attention avant de se
marier il n'y aurait pas tous les drames
qu'il ya aujourd'hui les gens sont crus
haut salat ça le fond du problème donc
pas divorcer et un grand conseil aussi
dans la grande série des grand conseil
de la baronne de rothschild jamais avoué
c'est la principale des choses c'est le
à bagnes si vous avez vous êtes vous
êtes morts d'abord il ne faut jamais
demander à votre mari est ce que tu m'as
trompé oui parce que bien entendu
vous êtes c'est dramatique d'entendre
oui on est trempés vous dites il va
chercher un peu à se faire pardonner
comme auprès de sa mère mais en fait une
femme lui pardonnera jamais bien des
façons voilà jamais alors messieurs s'il
vous plaît ne vous ai jamais ma vie où
j'avais dinars d'al hilal à agen alors
vous vouliez créé à mon jeu parce que
c'est devenu cette histoire une
assurance divorce
oui j'en ai parlé ce matin justement
avancer ça tient toujours pas ce que
c'est il ya longtemps de ça c'était
vraiment dans les années soit début de
70 acres et bien sûr quand je veux
quelque chose j'ai mais vous savez alors
quoi trouver l'âme soeur et assurance du
bord c'est à dire que je voudrais à
partir du moment où les hommes divorce
et les femmes divorce
ils doivent normalement payer une
pension alimentaire voici l'homme et de
bonne foi il paiera si malheureusement
il ne l'est pas la femme se retrouve
sans rien s'il perd sa situation même
s'il veut payer alors je crois qu'on
pourrait créer si vous voulez une
assistance ou les assurances se
substituerait à l'état ou aux marines
voilà mais alors pourquoi vous avez
arrêté d'en parler pendant 30 ans je le
savais mais revêtement non non pas du
tout non c'est que chaque fois que j'ai
présenté le projet on m'a dit c'est pas
réalisable c'est un encouragement au
divorce puis quand on voit qu'il y en a
tellement je me dis j'aime bien
encourager du tout par exemple vous êtes
pour le salaire maternel
oui j'ai pensé que les femmes devraient
toucher un salaire pour s'occuper des
enfants dans leurs bras pour pas pour
toutes les femmes pas pour toutes les
femmes vous avez des femmes sont tous
obligés de travailler qui gagne très peu
d'argent est alors à ce moment là je dis
pourquoi ne donne-t-on pas un salaire au
lieu de créer des crèches de construire
sans arrêt sans arrêt de nouveaux
établissements pour mettre des enfants
qui ont besoin de leur mère et des
femmes qui ne sont pas fait pour
travailler mais bon au moins qu'on leur
donne un salaire et tout le monde y
gagne
celles qui peuvent et qui ont
l'intelligence ou les études ou
houle envie surtout celles qui ont envie
pourquoi pas moi je fais absolument ravi
tout à fait pour vous pensez quoi des
chiennes de garde
écoutez moi j'admire beaucoup madame
alonso parce qu'elle elle un parcours
fantastique
elle est une très grande chef
d'entreprise j'estime que cette femme a
beaucoup de mérite de défendre
pardon vous pensez quoi des chaînes de
govou qui avait monté les lévriers
afghans de garde a pour l'heure pas
d'histoire non je crois qu'il en faut
je ne serais capable de faire le travail
qu'elle fait ça va pas bhl bon j'ai agi
d'une autre façon mais je pense qu'elle
est très très très utile au contraire
ouais vous la soutenait je ne dis pas
que je la soutiens sur tout mais il a
dit sûrement je la soutiens au bout des
rires dans le domaine de la génération
qui a touché bonne échappée la fin
attendue alors je suis maintenant
[Applaudissements]
vous étiez chez vous aussi s'il vous
plaît nadine de rothschild finalement
votre façon d'envisager la vie conjugale
ainsi vous venez nous le raconter est-ce
que c'est pas finalement la prostitution
bourgeoise
j'ai épousé un homme riche c'est vrai
mon mari mon mari n'était pas l'aider
sûrement pas un homme fidèle mais gelé
quand même gardé pendant 40 ans et je
voulais dit quand vous aimez quelqu'un
vous fait des sacrifices peu importe les
sacrifices vous avez à faire et je suis
contre le divorce et mon mari était un
homme extraordinaire j'étais sûr femme
et je le suis resté et voilà si c'était
à refaire je recommence tout de suite
l'amour est une affaire de femmes chez
robert laffont par aline de rothschild
donc page vous demander de recommencer
ronaldinho il faut apprendre il faut le
faire quand un clic et efforts avec les
mains ténue l'asie à leurs ébats films
montrés lui et sa 1/2 froid et intérêts
alors donc dans l'avant propos du livre
vous évoquez la disparition du baron
d'une façon assez tendre d'ailleurs
effectivement
et puis vous parler des femmes célèbres
que vous avez connu ou approché comme
actrice ou comme baronne de rothschild
alors on va essayer de les passer en
revue un petit peu voulu dire quelles
sont leurs spécificités
la première catégorie c les
marathoniennes alors dans cette
catégorie ya par exemple jackie kennedy
camilla parker bowles qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont de particulier les marathoniennes ce
sont des femmes qui aiment le pouvoir ce
sont des femmes qui ont envie d'être
célèbre donc elles savent qu'elles ne
peuvent être célèbre qu'à travers un
homme donc elles choisissent
effectivement l'homme qui va les mettre
sur un piédestal et qui fera d'elle la
star ou considérée comme une
marathonienne vous je pense oui oui
alors appris l ai pas de chance après
évidemment il a listé leurs il ya
marilyn monroe christina onassis romy
schneider
j'ai dis pas que ce soit je me régale
alors je dis pas que ce sens pas les pas
de chance je dis que ce sont des
midinettes qui veulent absolument que
l'amour soit au rendez vous bon l'amour
peut l'être cinq minutes mais pas toute
une vie donc c'est pour ça qu elisabeth
a tellement divorcer que remy
malheureusement est morte d'amour elle
est morte d'amour parce que c'est très
charmant de dire faucon même quand même
à tout prix mais c'est pas tout la vis
vous pensez qu'à un moment mais ça puis
de me faut continuer quand même non je
crois que la passion la passion ces cinq
ans je parle de la passion physique
bon après vous faites un accord vous
fait vous avez une vie avec des enfants
vous avez une vie très remplie mais ça
ne plus du tout la même chose vous
n'êtes plus la maîtresse vous êtes la
femme l'épousé la mère des enfants
l'accompagnent c'est différent ne pensez
pas qu'on puisse être à la fois la maman
et la [ __ ] vous a sûrement pas un
sûrement pas et heureusement d'ailleurs
alors après les mama alors celles qui
font des bons petits plats pour garder
leur mari alors il ya sophia loren et je
savais pas maria callas et lutter comme
soit maria callas
oui c'était une femme comme moi je les
ai vus vivre avec
avec onassis et s était vraiment la mama
les coéquipières là c'est simone
signoret qu montant hillary clinton avec
bill clinton son légendaire pardon dont
les charges de meeschaert alors c'est
quoi c'est ce que normalement une femme
doit être à un moment de sa vie
oui et ça me paraît tout à fait normal
moi j'étais une partenaire idéale avec
mon mari c'est à dire que on travaillait
ensemble dans beaucoup de choses et
c'est pour ça que je dis même si nous
avions divorcé il m'aurait posé parce
qu'on était on était à l'espèce de 10
l'extraordinaire les indépendances il ya
diana mona al youm c'est quoi les
caractéristiques et indépendante
ce sont des femmes qui veulent vivre
avec l'argent de leurs maris seul away
voilà et ça c'est très difficile parce
qu'une fois que vous avez cette
célébrité je pense qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'hommes qui s'intéressent à
vous parce que vous avez de l'argent
c'est très difficile pour une femme
d'être riche
seul il faut toujours un homme derrière
une femme vous savez vous terminez
baronne avec les admirables mais carla b
gamme que lui personne connaît l'enjeu
social et de rêver bière lager grace
kelly
oui farah diba oui en quoi elles sont
admirables non elles ont elles ont tenu
leurs engagements ils ont signé un
contrat ils sont allés au bout de leurs
de ce qu'elle avait signé moi je trouve
ça normal et bien
alors vous comprendrez comment les
aimants et nadine de rothschild qu'on
vous fasse une interview alerte aux
roses on a beau shooting en à gauche par
henry king est le lieu idéal pour faire
l'amour en combat tous les lieux sont
possible d'avoir un peu d'imagination
rolls plutôt oui plutôt que le métro
connaît le mot incroyable je donne un
beau chercher la sécurité ou la
performance la sécurité
est-ce que vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pour aimer ou des mets pour
faire l'amour
j'ai besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour
oui préfère un homme qui fait bien
l'amour mais qu'un fidèle ou un homme
qui fait mal l'amour mais qui est fidèle
elle même qui fait bien l'amour et qui
est un fidèle
vous préféreriez qu'un homme vous quitte
pour une femme ou pour un homme
je pense que là je serais très surprise
effectivement si c'était pour un homme
mais et puis pas non ça vous gênerait
plus que ce soit ça mais je ne jette pas
dans le flou non mais si vous aviez un
homme qui vous trompe avec un homme vous
auriez autant de compréhension que
c'était une femme si je ne peut pas
diriger je laisse faire
ouais voilà vous préférez un homme qui
couche avec une autre en pensant à vous
un homme qui couche avec vous en pensant
une autre c'est ce qu'on appelle quand
même si vous voulez quand un homme vous
dis je ne vous ai jamais trompé ma femme
alors j'ai dit moi je vois pas la
différence entre un monsieur qui va de
5h à 7h avec une dame et revient à la
maison avec un grand sourire de bonne
humeur quand monsieur qui le soir as le
même temps avec sa femme et qui pense à
la voisine mois n'est pas différent
fouet alors vous préférez finalement
j'ai couché avec une autre en pensant à
vous exactement elle s'ouvrait dans le
couple pose même pas la question dans le
couple il faut tous diront rien savoir
vous pensez qu'il faut rien savoir à 9
sans rien savoir
est-ce que vous pensez que embrasser
s'est trompé non non on peut embrasser
une femme ou un homme sans tromper
est-ce que sucer c'est tromper je ne
vais pas vous répondre
la numéro 6 de l'amour est une affaire
de femmes
[Musique]
merci on aligne on va vous laisser aller
vous coucher parce que j'attends les
jumeaux matin et centre nc qu'on veut
quand même que le psg marque des buts
un prochaine merci a bientot bienvenue
en france en tous les cas j'ai pris une
bonne leçon
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
[Musique]
j'accueille frédéric beigbeder
bonsoir l'on ma fille la baronne de
rothschild je vous avez des bonnes
manières vous tout vu
vous savez gérer les bars own way c'est
tout un boulot en année la baronne
disait que l'amour dure cinq ans vous
c'était trois ans dans votre bouquin
mais elle était restée mariée puisque 37
ans non non je ne dis pas que l'amour
dure 5 la passion vous dit
la passion physique moi ça fait 18 ans
que je suis avec ma femme s'est toujours
passionné
pourtant les gosses qui sont à côté mais
je n'ai jamais fait un homme riche
vous avez la chambre d'accord soigner
les couples et des français devons les
gosses d'accord j'ai compris fait
chambre à part un appartement à par
maison à part qui leur avaient été tirés
attention parce qu'elles pensent que
vous êtes riche donc elle va vouloir
vous faire divorcer et tout dernier le
même jour oui un croisé des liens entre
enyeama [ __ ]
depuis une pièce qui marche bien la
baronne qui s'est branché sur lui a tout
de suite ma ron fricke rang des objets
auxquels je n'avais pas accès par
exemple les du second plan personnel
vous d'écouter terry oui hein
c'est ridicule alors non je leur ai dit
que s'il avait bien c'est ça l'aidera
nature et oui on est passé à vitry à
laurent baffie bon frédéric comment ça
va ça va bien et bien tout va bien alors
vous êtes critique littéraire toute la
france ne vous connais pas encore fait
avec ces objets quand même de faire une
petite présentation
donc vous êtes critique littéraire à
voici au figaro littéraire
vous avez une plus maintenant j'ai plus
le temps pour le figaro ouais vous avez
une chronique consacrée qu'aux journaux
vraiment prestigieux
voici et vsd l'après-midi chronique dans
dans vsd ou vous raconter l'histoire
d'un personnage qui vous ressemble
beaucoup
qu'ils s'appellent oscars du fred wiki
et disons mois en pire
c'est un égoïste un lâche un [ __ ] un
obsédé enfin un homme quoi parce que
nadie dragon qui va dire le contraire
voilà est sympa nadine en plus elle nous
comprend bien nous les hommes
vous êtes critique littéraire aussi à la
radio au masque et la plume à france
inter à la télévision on travaille
ensemble dans rive droite rive gauche
sur paris première
et puis vous êtes un agitateur du milieu
littéraire vous avez créé la revue
énervé et puis le prix de flore dont
vous êtes le fondateur et secrétaire
général et le balayeur c'est le beau
leader évident surtout écrivain
vous avez publié cinq romans ou recueils
de nouvelles dont 99 francs vous avez lu
99 francs baronne non mais j'en ai
beaucoup entendu parler vos lacets tels
chiffres ça la fait rire
c'est un gros succès de la rentrée 2001
80 francs chez grasset rapporté là bas
tu écoutes mais les vendeurs justement
les ventes en mai où frédéric entre 300
et 350 milles mais sherpa oui je suis
pas super au courant des détails
combien de traduction l'étranger une
vingtaine il sortit en allemagne
oui la semaine dernière et donc on peut
lire le mans sont très très excité
l'adaptation au cinéma
oui en cours d'écriture - faut le lire
barona presse et l'amour dure trois ans
c'est génial aussi mais j'ai pas des
gens pour dire les boucles alors le
milieu du terrain nous a fait payer
comme un peu votre succès parce que vous
étiez sur toutes les listes des prix à
la rentrée mais rien même pas
l'interallié qui a été obtenu par
patrick poivre d'arvor
oui mais je pense qu'ils c'est pas
méchant ce que je vais dire et je pense
qu'ils n'avaient plus besoin que moi
franchement
est ce que l'arrivée où je n'avais pas
fait payer vos manières de dandy
frédéric au nom disant que c'est vrai
que j'ai une tronche énervante
j'y peux rien c'est quelque chose de
physique moi je dans ces cas-là il ya
deux solutions soit vous ramer à
contre-courant toute votre vie en
essayant d'expliquer aux gens que non en
fait vous êtes sympas soit vous devenez
vraiment une tête à claques
ouais j'ai choisi cette option là bas
j'étais un peu non je suis n'a pas le
snobisme il faut bien rappeler aux gens
c'est pas mal c'est aussi une forme de
curiosité les gens snobs c'est les gens
qui veulent connaître les trucs avant
les autres qui veulent finalement kiki
qui sont plus ouverts d'esprit peut-être
que les autres aujourd'hui vous publiez
dernier inventaire avant liquidation
voulais pas le faire je suis un chien
rebelles anti pub moi je vais passer
mais j'ai la rebelle
non je m'en branle et sexe magouille et
culture générale
oui oui oui j 1 h 42 46 79 70 donc fait
avec bd dernier inventaire avant
liquidation les 50 livres du siècle
choisi par vous et commenté par mois
voilà alors la méthode c'est simple ils
ont pris six mille personnes c'est la
fnac et le monde qui organise et ça
commence c'était un sondage 5,99 au
moment du tournant du millénaire où il
ya eu beaucoup de bilan dans tous les
domaines cinéma musique ça et il ya eu
un sondage auprès de 6000 personnes
en fait ils ont dû cocher sur une liste
de 200 noms ouais les les cinq ans cliff
qui préférait et ça donne une liste qui
est pas la meilleure mais pas la pire
non plus finalement il est à peu près
les gens qu'il faut il ya beaucoup
d'absents et aussi des gens qui
devraient pas être là mais en gros ça
donne mon avis les plus vertes à 50 de
la littérature du xxème siècle je suis
devenu le marc toesca des lettres alors
le 50 justement c'est nadja d'andré
breton et le 1 c'est l'étranger d'albert
camus ça vous semble l'étranger disons
que j'aurais pas choisi celui-là ouais
mais ça s'explique je pense que
l'étranger c'est un roman où il ya un
personnage qui incarne un peu l'homme du
20e siècle - c'est un antihéros
meursault qui sait pas trop pourquoi il
est là qui est un peu existentialisme
comme ça qui traînent sur une plage puis
tu es un mec puis les condamnés à mort
mais il s'en fout et très moderne
je crois que c'est très moderne et c'est
surtout écrit en 42 ski à c'est assez
incroyable c'est peut-être un des
premiers romans du nouveau roman avant
la lettre va vous dites je vois ce petit
opuscule comme une reconnaissance de
dette
quand tout d'un coup sur un malentendu
on se retrouve auteur d'un best-seller
la première chose à faire est de
renvoyer l'ascenseur j'espère que ce
livre donnera envie d'en acheter
d'autres et de meilleur c'est sympa mais
c'est à dire que
oui j'avais envie de montrer qu'on fait
pas un livre comme ça qui marche
ex nihilo ça ne vient pas de nulle part
je pense que c'est parce que j'ai
toujours eu une passion pour la
littérature et je voulais voilà est-ce
que c'est simplement une compil vous
apporter quelque chose de nouveau par
exemple chaussons nadja vous dites quoi
d'abord que quoiqu'il n'ait jamais été
dit c'est alors c'est pas essentiel
d'apporter forcément quelque chose de
nouveau j'ai pas la prétention
d'inventer
tout ce que je vais dire je crois que
j'essaie de faire quelque chose
d'amusant et de rapides
voilà sans prétention mais sur nadja il
ya une chose qui est vraie c'est qui
c'est un livre où il raconte ça rend sa
rencontre avec une prostituée
cocaïnomane qui finira l'asile et qui a
des dons de voyance un peu bizarre il ya
des photos dans le livre tout ça pour
dire que c'était peut-être 80 ans plus
tôt la même chose c'est ce qu'on voit en
ce moment et catherine millet jacques
henry c'était de l'auto fiction de
l'impudeur très en avance sur son temps
sur fitzgerald par exemple vous dites
quoi de nouveau qui n'est pas été dit je
dis que c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui voulait faire la
révolution en smoking et ça c'est bien
c'était sans doute le premier bobos on
parle beaucoup des bourgeois bohème en
ce moment disons qu oscar wilde et lui
étaient peut-être les premiers lots
saisis dans le métro vous dites quoi s
en asie alors ça c'est un truc
d'abord c'est un livre très drôle et
c'est aussi un livre d'avant-garde dire
que non faut bien se rendre compte que
c'est quelqu'un qui était parmi le les
gens les plus les plus inventifs sur le
langage
il a beaucoup inspiré san antonio par
exemple et donc c'est la preuve qu'on
peut être d'avant-garde sans être chiant
voilà ça c'est important
le lis tu as de nabokov voilà je suis un
peu je suis très fier d'une phrase bon
bah on connaît l'histoire c'est un
berbère un drap génère qui séduit une
lolita ça vient de là d'ailleurs ce ce
surnom qu'on donne aux séductrice très
jeunes 12 ans au début du livre et à la
symbolique sortent ensemble et à la fin
il la retrouve elle a 17 ans elle est
enceinte et là je suis assez content de
moi puisque j'ai écrit cette phrase
imbert imbert est déçue déçue mecs très
bien vous parlez de lévi-strauss aussi
vite que ses lentilles kouchner d'une
certaine façon oui parce qu'en fait
tristes tropiques c'est un essai ou
lévi-strauss dit les les peuplades les
ethnies d'amérique latine
il faut les respecter il faut les
laisser vivre il faut respecter leurs
traditions leur culture
nous les colonisateurs on n'a pas à
imposer notre mode de vie reste du monde
or aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup et je
moi je suis plutôt dans ce camp là je
pense que il ya un devoir d'ingérence
et qu'il faut pas laisser faire les uns
figuration et c'est donc donc on pourra
dire que lévi strauss est l'anti
kouchner enfin si vous voulez c'est tout
le temps dans le livre j'ai c'est de
simplifier les choses oui de regarder
les choses peut-être avec provocation
mais aussi simplement et c'est sexy
voilà de l'isc à ce qu'avait dit que
finalement c'est pas un visionnaire
c'est le siècle copié sur lui oui ben
non le procès c'est quand même
incroyable surtout début du siècle il
invente un monde de bureaucratie froide
totalitaire des langues qui sont
condamnés sans savoir pourquoi qui sont
complètement parano et on s'est aperçu
que tout le siècle à ressembler à ça
donc tout le monde dit kafka c'est un
prophète
moi je crois que c'est parce que
peut-être qui bien que c'est le siècle
qui a imité caf car il ya au pays dès
lors est eric zonca numéro 23 dans cette
liste un numéro 18
ouais quand même fou dont les dans les
grands c'est pas le plus grave
je trouve que c'est plus enfin je trouve
c'est embêtant que steinbeck dépasser
mille exemples je me suis amusé à faire
comme un hit parade avec yamaha chiens
qui montent machin qui descendra s'était
pas pagnol l'ailier albert comme son
copain 22e elle répare pas tout mais
non par exemple que proust soit second
que proust le poulidor du xxème siècle
ça me gêne un peu y'a pas le gérard de
villiers
ça c'est une honte vraiment un scandale
il a par frédéric beigbeder
ça c'est inadmissible il ya pas nadine
de rothschild ouais là solidaires qui
est en 3 en fait votre seul vrai sens
d'intérêt moi je le sais parce qu'on se
connaît bien c'est la littérature
je pense que si vous voulez je pensais
yama l'armée qui disait ça que le monde
existe pour arriver à un livre je crois
que vous je sais pas pourquoi j'ai une
obsession de de ça j'ai fait une préface
où j'essaie de répondre à cette question
sans y parvenir tout a évolué dans la
préface que la littérature c'est une
maladie un virus étrange qui vous sépare
des autres et vous pousser à accomplir
des choses insensées gelé la préface
[Rires]
voilà il fait son jean edern hallier
c'est pour la baronne qui fasse rêver
tout le livre
nous a très bien de faire ça c'est
justement la démarche du bouquin c'est
de dire arrêtons de respecter les
chefs-d'oeuvre c'est pas il faut
triturer les livres il faut arrêter
d'avoir peur et c'est vrai que l'école
nous apprend savoir espoir pourrait
avoir une sorte de respect idiots qui
finalement c'est ce que disait hemingway
un chef-d'oeuvre c'est un livre dans
tout le monde parle mais que personne ne
lit ça c'est bon je crois que c'est
c'est le cauchemar des shader et des
grands écrivains c'est de ne pas être
lui quand vous dites je souhaite qu'il y
ait encore des écrivains 21e siècle vous
avez peur que ce soit pas le cas je fais
un petit peu de parano mais je crois que
la littérature oui elle est menacée de
toutes parts elle est menacée par part
vous par nous le fait d'être à la télé
c'est un moment qu'on passe à regarder
un écran de manière passive sans en lire
en parenté est ce que vous allez partir
sur canal+ frédéric sitôt
comment baronne est ce que vous allez
partir sur canal à la mer en fait j'ai
pas envie de répondre maintenant oui est
ce que je trouve qu'il ya un truc très
confortable c'est le moment où on vous
veut un peu partout et vous êtes comme
comme une femme en train d'être un peu
draguer par plein de gens et j'aimerais
faire durer ce moment donc je n'ai pas
envie de répondre tout de suite parce
que là c'est pratiquement un ouais c'est
le luxe se sucrent mca se passe en
général au mois de mai dans la télé les
gens se téléphonent essaie de vous
laisser conter foot c'est le marché
mercato mercato et avant que ça dommage
que ça dure pas longtemps
voilà je sais une décision c'est
probablement la décision professionnelle
la plus la plus difficile de ma vie et
je suis tout à fait lucide sur la chance
que j'ai d'être dans cette émission avec
vous tesson qu'un écart mot sur paris
première qui est une liberté de parole
incroyable et là je deviens chiant mais
sincère
gonflé il vous est béarnais ex publicité
avait remercié doux interview mensonge
[Musique]
c'est votre côté rebelle qui vous pousse
ça pousse à bouger par un génial non je
suis la rebelle je suis la récalcitrante
voir l'insurgé vous êtes ultra libéral
sur le plan son plan politique veut très
proche d'alain madelin us d'alain minc
en fait oui vous vous trouvez pas que ce
système ultra libéral est porteur de
violence sociale frédéric ah non pas du
tout voulait rien un banc le marché
s'autorégule bon il ya des licenciements
massifs quand on fait des bénéfices mais
c'est très bien c'est pour la santé des
entreprises
oui beaucoup apprécié en france et je
les fais des bénéfices doit licencier
des gens en prévision du jour elle en
fera plus évidemment sinon leurs
actionnaires comment ils vivent
oui il faut je crois que c'est très
important que que les financiers
puissent s'engraisser un petit peu sur
le dos de des ouvriers non face à saint
frédéric est ce que vous partagez la vie
de jacques séguéla qui pensent que la
pub est là pour apporter du rêve et du
bonheur aux gens
oui d'abord je rédigerai saluer
l'artiste parce que jacques séguéla
c'est un artiste c'est un poète c'est
des temps modernes et je pense que la
publicité à la porte pas seulement du
bonheur elle elle est sincère quoi ouais
comme moi en ce moment
ouais il est sûr que ça vienne et
compris le possible aussi que séguéla
soit un artiste je suis d'accord
alors y'a un truc j'en vends pas à
frédéric avec vous là votre limousine
avec les vitres fumées ses assistants
qui sont toujours là pour vous allumez
les cigarettes c'est vous ça vraiment
oui parce que je pense que le pognon
c'est bien moi je trouve que je vis pour
ça et j'ai envie de voilà j'ai envie
d'avoir une une existence coupé du monde
coupé de la réalité
il écrase et des autres bien sûr
évidemment bien sûr ça va de soi ouais
et pourquoi avoir laissé tomber
l'ecstasy pour la cocaïne est certain
que jamais compris chez vous ça ah non
moi en fait j'ai jamais pris ni l'un ni
l'autre
ah oui ah non moi ça m'intéresse pas je
trouve que la drogue c'est pas bien ça
veut dire c'est c'est dangereux quoi il
faut jamais en prendre même un pétard
j'ai jamais fumé un pétard de ma vie
ouais quelle est la partie de votre
corps que vous préférez frédéric
m'habite compliqué là on se connaît bien
mais le hyaric maggio surprise chez vous
c'est cette incapacité à tromper la mère
de votre enfant même dans les situations
les plus propices aux vices finalement
quand vous faites interview mensonge
là-dessus lalalalalala voulait vraiment
coincé
non eh bien eh bien oui il la trompe
tout le temps je la trouve tout le temps
j'adore ça je pense qu'il faut se faire
sucer il faut il faut déjà que faciale
tous les soirs c'est tabou chez vous les
oreilles ma vie mais jacques faciale ou
fait 80 pages sur commencé et comment
et la bienséance dans les aides sociales
alors on à la baronne vous préférez bien
entendu frédéric kadhafi j magnin je
préfère ma fille excusez moi je suis
pour lui oui intellectuellement je ne
sais pas je me sentirais plus à l'aise
avec vous c'est vrai
ma fille kadhafi a fait fortune à ma
femme qu'on va solder tous les créneaux
c'est bon vous plaisez à madame de
fontenay madame de retirer parce qu'il
ya un truc qui se passe c'est marrant si
je sais il fut aux nobles c'est un peu
lolita à l'envers c'est bon frédéric
alors comment expliquer ce dégoût des
boîtes échangistes kivu qui ont détesté
ça moi je trouve cela honteux ces gens
qui qui qui veulent se met nu devant
d'autres personnes s'entassent et comme
ça ça me dégoûte
ça me dégoûte je trouve que tu as sont
globalement le sexe me dégoûte voilà ça
intéressant à jouer et les vacances en
thaïlande vous avez uniquement pour
écrire vous seulement alors c'est vrai
ouais budget de développement économique
du pays enfin votre double discours très
fait social mais c'est pour écrire oui
et aussi manger démangeait de m
cette recherche de sainteté nous allons
vous ça vient d'où
ça vient d'eux
du pape je crois que le pape c'est un
mec super
il va être content mais c'est
l'interview mensonge donc il est
perturbé est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec elle il isole quand tu dis
beigbeder c'est un mec bien
oui mais il n'est pas le seul à le dire
julie galles dalaï lama il ya nelson
mandela seulement 2 1 il a dit si
l'humanité était composé de beigbeder le
monde serait meilleur
annoncé par vaclav havel qui a dit ça
aussi je dînais avec kofi annan et
boutros boutros ghali et ils me disent
frédéric ce que vous faites pour pour
l'humanité nous fait chialer de bonheur
et moi je
l'ua
bien frédéric beigbeder a connu son
premier succès dans la pub avec une
campagne pour les soutiens-gorge
vendeurs bras c'est une jolie fille qui
disait regardez moi dans les yeux j'ai
dit les yeux et bien frédéric cadeau ce
soir elle est là précise gilles gaubert
prendre mais on y va je vous ai
interviewé une première fois en 1994 et
vous m'avez dit à cette époque là
j'étais absolument désolés aucun homme
ne m'a jamais dit tu sais et vac de
beauce est ce que depuis on vous l'a dit
c'est un pas arrivé parce que je crois
qu'elle est jean et sont beaucoup plus
intéressés par à quoi je suis intérieure
et pas quoi mais c'est suit l'interview
mensonge là je veux dire la vérité
donc j'avais un destin extraordinaire
vous connaissez le destin des valeurs
saint gobain
on a que j'avais ressentie par les biens
à sa formidable s'élève voilà une fille
voilà j'aurais voulu avoir une fille
comme elle
oui vous pouvez adopter ce soit on va
vraiment du destin extraordinaire le
laurent baffie qui finira dans la peau
de sacha guitry faut bien le dire
elles ont sillonné ce qu il ya de l
escaut dubillard normes et nadine
veulent un destin extraordinaire et
evans la petite natte des noëlles
d'école les années 50 et qui est venu la
baronne je suis sûr contre vous il ya un
truc mais parce qu'elle est née le même
jour un match et on va se revoir
honnêtement j'ai l'impression que vous
lui pardonner tous qui dit ils peuvent
dire des trucs collective et une
tendresse pour lui quoi vous plaisir et
beaucoup amené ayoub aussi oui c'est ma
paie pour ça que j'étais elle pensait
que j'étais gay donc on revient vous eva
herzigova dont vous êtes né en
tchécoslovaquie avant la scission la
scission de la tchécoslovaquie a donné
quoi
je veux travailler sur le service public
ça s'est même pas plus là le début du
mois la fin du monde petit indice
petit indice la tchéquie et la slovaquie
oui monsieur alors dans un petit village
au nord de la tchéquie
ils s'en foutent de ce pays voilà
heureusement maintenant se fout un peu
d'histoire du pays devant les nichons
voix risque qu'un des pays
ouais voilà heureusement qu'ils et
adriana karembeu eva herzigova
s'intéresse et la tchéquie la république
tchèque et william hill and kundera
aussi mis au lit et voila voila c'est
bien dit dont 1 alors votre père était
électricien dans une compagnie minière
votre mère était secrétaire et à
l'époque avant la révolution de velours
avant vaclav havel justement vous viviez
dans un pays difficile enfin à l'époque
vous en rendiez pas content évidemment
c'est comme quand nadine de rothschild
habiter à puteaux sous la chape de plomb
du communisme donc vous ne saviez rien
de ce qui se passait à l'ouest à
l'époque et votre grand mère vous aider
confie dans son secret elle vous disais
quoi votre grand mère quand elle vous
parlez quand vous étiez petit qu'elle
voudrait de l'époque d'avant le
communisme
ma grand mère en fait qu'elle a eues il
est tellement 1 104 ans elle était très
ouverte elle chantait à la vieille
green deal with him in elle m'a raconté
les histoires il m'a raconté comment cet
appel s'est passé dans l'est dans
l'ex-anpe de donc a été très sereine et
m'a toujours dit il faut jamais raconté
à personne parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on était allé en prison voilà dans
quoi eva herzigova a été élevé sur un
pays disons le totalitaire et pourtant
vous dit qu'à l'époque du communisme les
gens étaient plus solidaire et
qu'aujourd'hui sont plus jaloux plus
envieux ils sont un peu plus jaloux
parce qu'avant et avait avait pas la
différence dont on avait la même chose
n'avait pas le choix
et maintenant il ya les gens qui sont
plus riches et revient à jeter les gens
qu'ils en plus talentueux qu'ils ont
envie de travailler le plus c'est bien
sûr c'est cela qui ce qui reste encore
avec alors on sait dans le vieil
assystem
ils sont jaloux mais ce qu'il sent
qu'ils sont fainéants alors l'époque
quand vous étiez petit 10 ans j'étais
pas un fantasme comme vous dites
vous-même d'ailleurs vous étiez plutôt
plate renom comme s'ils étaient très
minces je me suis développé tcc retardé
oui non plus maintenant
non mais elle était très très retardé et
complexé par votre soeur jalouse un peu
de votre soeur qui avait trois ans de
plus que vous mais c'est elle qui avait
le succès avec les uns c'est elle qui
était peu stèle qui avait les salles
les chenilles dans les élites étaient
bien ronde
c'est un ton parce que c'est toi qui
ramassent tôt maintenant elle et elle
est toujours très belle et je trouve
qu'elle est elle a des enfants est un
élevage de canon comme ça c'est des
belles filles bien un jour voilà où
cette extraordinaire son histoire il
habite donc à litvinov près de la
frontière allemande comme je les dis et
un jour ils vont à prague avec vos
parents vous partez après pour visiter
des musées et vous rencontrez une amie
prague qui vous dit eva ya une agence
française qui fait un casting qui
organise un concours il y avait 400
fille et c'est vous qui gagnez je ne
voulais pas aller si c'était dans un
hôtel un hôtel intercontinental c'était
un neuvième étage je me rappelle très
bien je suis arrivé avec toutes les
filles qui se ressembler à ma soeur mon
cas je me suis pas trouvé belle je me
suis dit mais qu'est ce que je fais ici
j'ai d'ailleurs je suis parti tout de
suite je partais mais la fin de paris
qui est qui est venue d'organiser ce
concours et marc marquez et elle a couru
a couru après moi moi j'étais en
attendant l'ascenseur
elle m'avait dit tu venu à paris tu mets
et voilà eva herzigova débarque à paris
il faut dire en plus que vos parents il
était très strict avec vous c'est à dire
que jusqu'à l'âge de 16 ans quand vous
allez au cinéma l'après midi que le film
se terminer à 8 heures il fêtera la
maison à 8h05 raconter l'histoire
racontée et l'a donc vous débarquez à
paris et le ce qui vous a le plus
fasciné c'est des étalages de fruits et
légumes ont un
c'étaient les couleurs je crois c'était
pas vraiment c'était bien sûr le choix
parce qu'on n'avait pas mais je trouve
je crois que c'était la possibilité là
où que c'était ouvert qu'ils n'ont pas
eu peur qu'il ya quelqu'un qui va les
volets les trucs comme ça
oui parce que chez view manger surtout
des pommes de terre non c'est très laid
c'est une tradition
on échange beaucoup de la viande et la
pomme de terre je reste fasciné par les
gadgets ou pas il dit les filles de
l'est ce que ça peut encore vous allez
rentrer alors vous avez du mal à vous
adapter non pas à paris mais au parisien
moi j'y pense à que vous parler de cette
histoire où je suis allée acheter une
baguette à la place de dire une jeudi un
bras et ils m'ont dit en disant que
qu'est ce que je veux qu'il comprenne
pas la baguette c'est la baguette
si j'arrive à qui ça fait trente ans
qu'elle n'a pas mangé de pain je suis
fasciné mais c'est vrai quand vous avez
dit braguette bon je vais le regarder
nadine plein de compassion pour vous
mais c'est incroyable est en train
progressivement de tomber m qui peut
amoureux ce n'est pas un petit peu mais
servent à tuer en train progressivement
de faire fortune alors j'ai été très
surprise par les prix en arrivant à
paris quand vos parents sont venus vous
visitez à paris pour une visite vous les
avez logés à l'hôtel costes et vous
cacher les prix parce que vous aviez un
plomb du prix que ça coûte et non oui
parce que hélas elle pensait à tout ce
qu'elle pouvait avoir en tchécoslovaquie
parce qu'elle est pris entre 6 à la
basse au prix d'un petit déjeuner au cas
où on peut vivre un moment que vous êtes
devenu donc pour une nuit au formule 1
la weiss achète une voiture vous êtes
devenu très rapidement à un grand pas de
plus belle comme je dédie et on regarde
en tout huit mois
[Musique]
tous
non non non
[Musique]
m
magnifique et l'asie l'honneur
alors ça c'est vers des mauvaises
nouvelles
alors question cinéma vous avez eu moins
la main heureuse vous avez joué dans les
anges gardiens avec depardieu et
claviers et puis alors un film s'appelle
amicaux delcourt et de vincenzo salem
qu'on n'a pas trop vu et la just for de
time being par jill brenton quêtes
annexes de santa barbara mais surtout là
où je veux en venir c'est que vous avez
refusé de jouer dans le kubrick
ce fils et notre film culte eyes wide
shut c'est le plus beau film sur le
couple qui était fait c'était très
difficile a décidé parce qu'en vrai
qu'il fait un film toutes les vingt ans
ouais et il est mort quel dommage mais à
la rolls qui m'a été proposé je voulais
même aujourd'hui je n'aurais pas accepté
parce que le rôle c'était ce n'est pas
si t'es pas s'étaient présentés pour moi
comme un corps comme une beauté moi je
suis j'y suis là dans la partie dans le
château dans la soirée d'enchères
représente déjà la beauté dans un métier
je veux pas faire la même chose moi la
nôtre ou si c'était à refaire vous
diriez non un kubrick une fois de plus
pour la même rôle riz alors question un
mausolée tout parce qu'en 94 vous
m'aviez dit je n'ai pas encore rencontré
l'homme de ma vie j'ai compris en vous
posant la question que ce serait pas moi
depuis on vous a vu beaucoup avec vous
mêmes et est marié avec tico torres le
batteur de bon jovi mariage qui a duré
deux ans et alors un jeu où il ya une
histoire je veux savoir où sont nés
parce que l'histoire est formidable vous
êtes un matin sur le port de new york
dans un hangar en train de faire des
photos pour calvin klein avec jean
baptiste mondino avec un mannequin qui
s'appelle kelly rippy fait des photos
avec lui est alors un moment mondino
jean baptiste mondino photographe
appelle la directrice des communications
de calvin klein et 10g même plus besoin
de les diriger
ils sont vraiment tombés amoureux c'est
à dire que pendant la photo vous êtes
tombée amoureuse de ce qu'elle irait
pinon je suis extrêmement jaloux bien
entendu et alors est ce que ça dure
toujours
c'est une vieille histoire on lance un
appel
un moment positif dans cette émission
que positif c'est pas la peine de lancer
un appel en europe
non c'est fini j'ai fait j'ai fait une
connerie d'en parler c'est l'histoire du
mal à ça fait toujours du mal je crois
que chaque fois aussi mis ensemble avec
quelqu'un on pense que c'est pas pour la
main pour tout le temps et a fait en
cherchant charge charge est aujourd'hui
voulait lancer un appel à la télévision
non java pas que ça va être si public
mais je crois ça a marché on me marier
la route so on n'a plus revu depuis
c'était un peu mais qu'il a épousée ou
est-ce qu'il a embarqué parce qu'on n'a
plus jamais revu bien ben écoute et on
va voir justement ce que vous seriez
prête à faire ou pas par amour parce que
c'est important que les français sont au
courant ça s'appelle interview par amour
et vous savez que vous
[Musique]
on a beau chemin pendant le génial
il ya deux connards de rebelles ce soir
heureusement que le cadreur et
d'affichés qui bouge la caméra parce que
donc par amour est ce que vous seriez
prête à sacrifier vos ambitions
professionnelles pour l'amour pour le
vraiment vraiment oui vous y croyez
toujours au vrai amour heureusement ou
malheureusement 6,8 à l'île de ré
pendant madame la baronne peut répondre
alors est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à refuser un film avec
steven spielberg
bien sûr pour l'amour pour tous pour
poursuivre votre fiancée vous dis je
refuse que tu tournes avec vous et c'est
exactement la théorie de madame la
baronne qui dit quand on aime quelqu'un
on le laisse vivre
m on a de la chance ce soir en mettre
deux femmes très très grands principes
j'espère que les autres en prendront
intelligence et où vous avez raison en
baronne est ce que par amour vous
retourneriez vivre en république tchèque
la technologie
je crois que si on trouve l'amour et
nous ramène d'accord bien est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à vous faire
refaire les seins
sinon ce sera pas un mois encore
ouais c'est pas un vrai amour un type
qui demanderait une peur du goba se
faire refaire les choses soient un
connard vous serez pas un vrai amour
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
ne pas faire d'enfant ça c'est difficile
difficile à un mec qui vous dit je
t'aime on se marie mais moi je déteste
les enfants j'en veux pas c'est pas
possible c'est lé fruit de l'amour c'est
automatique c'est naturel que ça vienne
est-ce que par amour vous aideriez votre
votre homme a caché le corps de
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer
ah mais vous aussi oui ouais mais vous
préférez
mais oui après j'ai écrit un livre
là-dessus l'avantagé la littérature
c'est tout semble avoir un sens
subitement alors ça c'est une question
importante c'est la question de clotilde
courau clotilde courau qui est une jeune
actrice très talentueuse d'ailleurs nous
a dit que par amour quand elle était
plus jeune elle embrasse et 100 fois de
suite les chaussettes sales de son
fiancé c'est possible vous le feriez
vous à vous non non non non des limites
vous avez jamais finir c'est pas le pire
encore on peut dire à nadine vous avez
jamais vécu et que le batteur
avec boris vian ouais c'est vrai nom
nadine venir à bout il devait avoir 25
ans j'en avais 16 des 20 years ago va s
que par amour
vous accepteriez que votre fiancée et
une maîtresse
j'aurais mal à supporter j'aurais
j'aurais très mal oui mais si vous
voulez mais vraiment voulais qu'il soit
heureux mais c'est d'éduquer de la
france entière que c'est compliqué 6 il
amène sa maîtresse et que vous faites un
truc à 3 à st pas lasser mais ça c'est
pas besoin d'être assistés sur le point
d'être plein mais elle n'a pas besoin
d'être assistés à son âge
bon oui mais un peu comme ça quand même
un usager lallaing
c'est pas les déchets après derrick en
banque et singer l'odyssée pas non
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête à
aller dans une boîte échangiste tous les
samedis soirs
m
oui le régime
[Applaudissements]
on y va ce soir c'est pas non c'est non
non un samedi sur deux à un samedi sur
deux tous les 15 jours parce que je
pense à l'amour et si j'avais vraiment
qu est-ce qui ça ça apporte le mec fait
ce qu'il veut c'est la groupe et il sait
pas vraiment mais c'est en fait ils se
sont fait pas fantasmer que la une
partie de cet homme je sait pas assez
mais non ça ne s'impliqueraient pas
d'accord si ces quatre conscience là
quand même hein est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle et la france entière bons gags
moi le premier
frédéric hallucinant cet homme qui
réalise ans qui arrive à imposer comme
sortir des trucs de malade
les sensations avec moi il faut le
savoir c'est dément est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à grossir de 10 kg si
le type aime bien les rues basses les
formes êtes d'accord
quittant votre héros vous êtes vous
apparemment on grossit de 10 kilos ça
s'appelle tomber enceinte
sigma
notre invité ce soir
laurent avant de vous saluer je voulais
quand même faire quelques emails parce
que c'est important
michaël blanc qui est quelqu'un que nous
aidons dans cette édition qui est
enfermé à bali la prison à perpétuité
été condamné à mort pour du shit nadine
qu'est ce qui fait un peu cheap un peu
de chichon un peu de cabanis
c'est un lecteur en plus c'est ouais
empêcher des bébés nés dans sa prison
donc le jugement je le dis le jugement
en cassation aura lieu autour du 20 25
mais on ne sait pas encore bien décision
en tous les cas de la cour à bali avant
la fin mai et la seule chose à faire
pour aider michael blanc c'est d'envoyer
de l'argent le site s'écrit là pendant
que je parle sur l'écran en bas de
l'écran d'henri de l'argent parce que
pour sa famille c'est très cher les
voyages à bali tout ça et puis faudrait
peut-être filer un petit bakchich aux
gens là-bas en indonésie parce que pour
qu'ils le libèrent voilà et c'est pas
parce que il ya love story qui font
oublier ceux qui sont vraiment en prison
et qu'ils n'ont pas choisi voilà alors
un remake de steely un email de steevy
qui dit j'attire les philippines aziz m
me prendre sous la douche suis-je gay
séparemment julien
ce qui dit j'espère qu'un jour tu
remplacera michel drucker le dimanche
après midi
non clairement dans un e-mail de farid
de long se cacher son père veut pas le
reconnaître je vois pourquoi et un email
de christelle kumm ans qui habite à
beauchamp et c'est un message pour karim
qui est dans la maison d'arrêt du val
d'oise et lui dit ta petite brindille et
moi on pense bien fort à toi non
non ma vie
et maintenant j'accueille c'est un truc
qui l'énervent à chaque fois donc à
chaque fois que je lui mais ce sont les
nerfs du baiser fonte oublier serge july
ah ah
serge july bonsoir par contre libération
assis à côté de nadine de rothschild
finalement marqué vous venez de faire un
bouquin avec alain juppé donc en même
temps pas tout à fait pareil mais enfin
normes enfin bon tout est possible quoi
c'est le monde moderne
ça va ça va très bien vous connaissez la
vigne de rothschild oui oui nous sommes
en couple mais eva herzigova serge oui
ça c'est la première fois par an tous
voilà le pas la dernière
et frédéric beigbeder donc l'auteur de
l'année frédérique bel ébat dit quelque
chose quand je dis l'auteur de l'année
justement je dis rien je suis tout à
fait d'accord
problème vous le répéter l'auteur de
l'année bien serge july dans vous publié
chez grasset un livre d'entretiens avec
allain jules guesde
drôle d'idée on va en parler mais
d'abord
à ces jeux c'est fou quand même à ça je
peux pas c'est à dire il fait des livres
avec alain juppé mais quand il est
question de faire celle toujours
révolutionner mais je n'arrive pas à
faire le singe j'y arrive pas je peux
dire des conneries verde conway message
si vous connaissez la punition
l'accréditation vous la connaissez la
punition c'est la punition bien alors
c'est une veillée de jean-claude
fasquelle
ça s'appelle entre quat'zyeux donc
depuis février 98
reevoo rencontré alain juppé pour
dialoguer waouh
et à quel rythme ça dépend des on a fait
je crois 25 entretien
c'est toujours intéressant de voir
quelqu'un quand il est en pleine 10
grammes et oui ça sent d'ailleurs quand
il est dans la défaite quand il est vous
faites une émission je sais ça revient
donc là il n'est pas encore revenu sur
glace et c'était parti et donc c'était
assez intéressant outre plein plein de
raisons je pouvais avoir mais de deux
suivent y compris l'actualité pendant
que nous en prenons notre temps
de manière assez paresseuse on n'a pas
fait sa manière intensive
enfin oui alors finalement ça a duré
jusqu'au début de cette année
pourquoi le patron de libération aide
alain juppé à s'humaniser parce qu'en
fait c'est son problème et jupe et
maintenant il faut qu'ils expliquent
qu'il est pas un expert comptable qu'il
a avec un coeur et tout pourquoi est-ce
que say we may say vous pourquoi vous
prêtez à ça mais moi d'abord quand j'ai
commencé quand je me suis engagé là
dedans
j'ai accepté parce que il représentait à
droite
moi je suis de gauche donc il ya trois
d'ambiguïté possible
il est représenté à droite une droite
qui résistaient au front national qui
était sur la cuisse et passionnelle je
pense que c'est vraiment il était
absolument la transition serait pas été
le cas je vais j'aurais refusé jean
millon vous l'auriez pas fait quoi g ou
d'autres mais moins en paix j'aurais pas
ça ne va pas toucher à ça mais lui
c'était une manière il avait au moins ça
et puis
c'est un type qui a essayé de faire des
réformes qui est d'une maladresse quand
même non seulement politiques mais enfin
qui dans des choses simples quoi et
quand même incroyablement maladroit
saviez tout ça est assez intéressant on
peut dans notre métier choses toujours
on rencontre des gens qui sont pas
forcément les gens et qui on partage sa
vie on a envie de partager sa vie mais
on a envie de comprendre comment ça
fonctionne vous êtes aux antipodes l'un
de l'autre c'est clair alors on dort
j'avais envie en 68 vous on sait le rôle
que vous avez eue en 68 on n'a pas la
dernière fois que vous étiez là je lui
ai serré par épisode on en fait par
épisode on fait la saga de science julie
qu'en données ajustées
donc non mais juppé en 68 il dit je ne
comprenais pas vraiment ce qui se
passait et la référence à mao me
stupéfié donc vraiment on peut pas aller
plus loin de vous c'est une idée parce
que ça commence par jules et deux
peut-être peut-être parce qu'elle a eu
l'idée je sais pas il disait il disait
en parlant 68 je fais je n'ai jamais vu
que l'aspect agitation politique en
prenant 68 la chienlit comme disait de
gaulle et je suis allé manifester le 30
mai avec les gaullistes donc vraiment
effectivement ça peut être quelqu'un qui
est plus loin que vous alors parlons lui
justement parce que vous l'avez
fréquenté pendant qu'on faisait livrer
25 fois c'est courageux quand il était
premier ministre il a essayé de faire
des grandes réformes libérales sur la
sécurité sociale les impôts réformer
l'état et il a échoué face à l'hostilité
de l'opinion publique est ce que vous
croyez qu'il valait mieux que les
résultats de son action dans l'histoire
de juppé il y avait quelque chose qui
m'intéressait aussi moi j'ai toujours
fait des articles très violents ce
moment par les allemands c'est très dur
et puis c'est vrai quand il ya eu cette
réforme de la cedh de la sécurité
sociale
libération a titré juppé lodève pourquoi
parce que c'était un combat comme menait
depuis très très longtemps la cfdt et
qu' il a monté essayer de monter sa
réforme en s'appuyant sur la cfdt ce qui
était bizarre déjà comme attelage comme
montage d'une certaine manière la cfdt a
eu plus de facilité avec juppé qu'elle
n'en a eu avec jospin
donc je trouvais ça voilà intéressant
finalement cette partie de sa réforme
est resté de ce qu'ont dit les réformes
on n'arrive pas cette partie rester mais
il a eu la très mauvaise idée de vouloir
faire trois choses en même temps c'est à
dire à la fois de réformer le système de
retraites des cheminots à la grève
générale dans la ville plus une réforme
la sncf
évidemment il réussit le monde
actuellement de paris souvenirs en
national passe à s'ouvrir à paris
paralysée pendant pendant trois semaines
oui mais avait pas de paris il a fait
c'était quand même il a vivement c'est
assez chargé et alors ce qu'il raconte
d'ailleurs que tu as assez drôle j-10
tout le monde l'avait averti lui avait
dit vous savez c'est pas bien de faire
ça vous fait ailleurs ça va mal se
passer
ils avaient été avertis donc c'est pas
du tout le fait qu'on n'avait pas averti
il a pensé qu'on est pressé ou non n'a
pas de temps à perdre et je trouve que
là aussi ça m'intéresse pas c'est le
raisonnement du technocrate croyait
qu'il avait investis soit la chine va et
le raisonnement c'est celui-là perdons
pas de temps puisque l'idée elle est
évidente
allons-y et donc il en fait trois en
même temps mais là on n'a pas fait que
ça quand même
il s'est pris dans le tapis c'est un
fait que ça il a viré des jupettes
siècle a commencé par mettre des filets
gouvernement et puis six mois après les
aménager pour faire rentrer des
balladuriens voilà la cuisine voilà
c'est là qu'on ne dit pas qu un machiste
pluies d'octobre 95 quand les cinq ans
quand chirac a arrêté la fracture
sociale et qui est revenue vers le
vernis là il a une épopée gouvernement
il a fait évacuer les sans papiers de
l'église saint bernard
voilà il a dit en novembre 96 que
thomson multimédia ça valait 1 franc
voilà enfin c'est quand même chercher
ses charges et je veux pas faire un
procès à charge mais en face c'est vrai
quand même mais là il a un passif le
garçon la wii alors et à la mairie de
bordeaux en boire du bon vin c'est
là-bas josiah les entretiens non
j'habite bordeaux cru pour vous pour nos
crus pour maintenant pour pour tout le
monde
il est adoré à bordeaux oui à l'époque
il dit j'avais atteint un tel degré
d'impopularité comme premier ministre
que ça se ressentait même dans le regard
des bordelais maintenant il a fait ses
preuves oui quand tu mets très apprécié
oui on va devoir se faire à droite il
n'y a pas que monde veut dire donc si
c'est pas ce qui se passera en 2002
ma main après
juppé risque d'être quand même avec l'ap
vous pensez qu'il va revenir à l'époque
vous écriviez des trucs terribles ces
comportements autoritaires chérie c'est
vrai chef d'un gouvernement pts 6 core i
j c'est vrai il gère le pays en expert
comptable enfin voilà quoi tout ça est
vrai je revendique absolument l'avoir
écrit ça et d'ailleurs
juppé quand on s'est lancé dans ces
entretiens il avait le dossier de presse
où il y avait la ferme il alla et quand
j'ai sur le questionnement je suis resté
absolument je suis là ils s'appellent
entre cadieux le précédent s'appeler
entre nous il ya beaucoup d'imagination
pour les titres alors sur entre nous
vous aviez écrit c'est un opuscule écrit
à l'heure de la sieste c'est l'attitude
d'un général autiste qui fonce et
n'entend rien exact juppé a disparu dans
le triangle des bermudes de la politique
alors sérieusement pourquoi la mission
énergie pour que non mais pourquoi juppé
je pense qu'on l'a il ya plein de gens
si vous avez envie de faire un livre
d'entretiens avec quelqu'un il ya plein
de gens en france qui mérite nom vous
dit un homme politique de droite vouliez
pas un philosophe un écrivain oui nos
messages pourraient toujours le faire où
j'en ai fait d'autres interviews des
paquets et quand même tout par
profession 1
mais d'abord un c'est une proposition de
jean-claude fasquelle et elle est
intéressée chercheuse parler de commande
qu'on ne sait pas non c'est pas ma place
ici on est venu me trouver pour faire
quelque chose qui était bizarre et donc
sa main ça m'intéressait de ckoi la
droite
voilà ça moi ça m'intéresse c'est de
savoir ça et vaut mieux parler avec des
gens
avec lesquels on n'est pas d'accord oui
oui je trouve c'est plus intéressant
c'est la maillotine air d'atonie sienne
merci voilà ça excitant que
d'interviewer quelqu'un à qui je pouvais
partager beaucoup de choses vous croyez
cela on a vraiment on partage peu de
choses vous pouvez qu'un avenir
politique
je pense parce que je crois que là le
problème de la droite parlementaire
française c'est qu'il ya personne way et
qu'il ya énormément de gens invalidée à
l'emploi piètre nouvelle génération qui
arrive mais compte tenu du fait qu'en
français comme les vins de bordeaux il
faut les garder pendant assez longtemps
en cave
donc voilà donc il se trouve que l'on
tombera sur jupe est donc là parce que
ce qui dit quand même sur son retour
c'est quand même pas époustouflants et
d'ici la droite revient au pouvoir en
2002 on fera une réforme fiscale qui en
soit une
c'est pas non plus un programme
politique et son passé c'est pas
excitant mais parce qu'ils payent les
impôts je les paye aussi oui quand il
dit il faudra endiguer la montée de
l'insécurité
quand même pas non plus et à laurier oui
je dirais empêcher qui valent à st j'ai
pas pu empêcher qu'à la fin un seul yves
ils disent quand même deux trois choses
sur elle à dire ouais donc c'est pas la
partie quand je dis l'europe la vague
jossic si oui quand il l'europe que ce
soit une fédération d'états nations bond
de l'ordre de l'or l'a dit il ya déjà
des lustres en voilà d'ailleurs quelle
paire de cette formule assez
incompréhensible oui bien le dire alors
le il ya un truc intéressant et enfin il
ya plein de trucs intéressants mais là
où le chapitre 6 appelle les mystères de
paris il ya quoi dit assad à 100 là il a
eu raison
oui voilà c'est tout ces types dont il y
avait des emplois fictifs militant du
rpr en fait qui étaient salariés par la
mairie de paris c'est le dossier du juge
des murs et alors ils vraiment 30
millions de francs qui ont été versés
par la mairie de paris pour entretenir
le repère alors lui il se défend après
midi ya jamais eu un système organisé
mais des employés de la mairie qui
militent et peut-être trop oui
nie pas que c'était des emplois voilà me
dit bon humilité troll c'est à dire
qu'effectivement c'est pas l'avocat ni
d'un compresseur mais en gros il dit oui
il y avait des emplois fictifs et la
seule chose qu'il dit pour sa défense il
dit quand je suis arrivé il y en avait
tant la loi avait été votée 95 et 93 et
donc à partir de ce moment là il devait
plus y en avoir ou qu'un et j'ai mis 2
ans ou à nos ennemis ouais pour les
faire disparaître mais quand je suis
parti je les ai faits ils avaient tous
disparu on va la dernière question votre
verdict sur l'homme juppé je dirais que
c'est d'abord ce qui m'a frappé parce
que je connaissais très mal je l'avais
joué quelques fois à la télévision mais
je connaissais assez mal alors qu' à
venise les premiers ça maintenant bien
longtemps je suis en bien il en vient à
dire un lieu de vie des spectateurs qui
écrit un livre qui s'appelait la
prédation et il revient de venise s'il
aime beaucoup de venir je crois qu'il ya
quelque chose il ya un rapport entre lui
et venise au sens mort à venise
non oui maintenant dix ans plus tôt
minérale il assez minérale venez c'est
un homme un peu de pierre et je crois
qu'il est un coup l'instinct homme seul
il ya une pudeur je crois commence
durable et que quand il a une audace
comme souvent les gens qui ont beaucoup
de pudeur fait très violent maladroit
voilages alors qu'il est verdict sur
l'homme comme ça
il est finalement je le trouve
mais un peu a contrario et je vais dire
ça de manière un peu par le ya quelque
chose d'émouvant chez
ban
interview technicolor en attendant le
single on avoue shooting alors ce soir
s'ils arrêtent tout le monde bouge ses
porte nawak la non mais je crois pas ça
well que des révolutionnaires bec bédié
julie baffie
heureusement que nos amis tchèques sont
respectueux du règlement
alors là c'est une révolution de velours
la vraie exactement serge july ce qui
vous rend vert de rage
moi qui suis pas du tout pour
l'interdiction de quoi que ce soit en
particulier pas de loft story mais enfin
oui ça me rend un peu vers de vraies
rencontres expliqué que votre
chroniqueur télévision david dufresne il
a expliqué comme daniel schneidermann
dans le monde d'ailleurs au départ est
trouvé ça formidable il ya une semaine
après ils ont commencé à mettre un peu
aimée parce que un journal
qui fait par des journalistes oui c'est
pluriel ouais donc vous ça vous énerve
plus que david dufresne
- oui voilà mais c'est le côté vous
savez dans cette affaire-là
ça me rappelle une pièce que vous devez
connaître est une très belle pièce de
théâtre qui s'appelle la dispute de
marivaux on passe aux xviiie et il ya
deux aristocrates qui s'interroge sur
l'amour c'est comment ça se passe
l'infidélité entre les gens commencent à
nay et il dit si il décide de dire bon
on va voir on va faire un exercice on va
prendre quatre jeunes gens deux filles
deux garçons ça se passe au xviiie
siècle
deux jeunes filles deux jeunes garçons
qui n'ont eu aucune histoire on va les
faire élevé par des serviteurs qui n'ont
absolument aucun contact
et puis quand ils seront grands
adolescents ben on verra ce qui se
passera ce qui se passe il se passe une
tragédie et ça fait penser à ça voilà la
différence c'est que c'est marivaux qui
écrit alors que la cei marie pour qui
écrire oui là il n'y a pas de scénario
dialogues alors n 1 qui écrivent même
structure mais c'est terrible cette
histoire parce que quand libération fait
sa une avec love story on y voit là 15%
de plus donc que les parce que c'est
dans une ville d'un point de vue
sociologique c'est une des questions les
plus patiente qui soit moi je je
remercie m6 d'avoir fait cette émission
pourquoi alors je suis vert de rage
pourquoi mais parce que c'est le plus
grand débat qu'on a eue sur la
télévision d'un traître ou tendon était
très bien c'est la der la der de l'année
choisies sur aziz oui finalement s'avère
ce qu'il veut est reconnu en lui
demandait pourquoi pour être connu ouais
bah oui mais non t'as pu besoin gras cru
en lui pour être solide comme on est
dans une émission de télévision c'est en
gros c'est une vision du paradis
terrestre un seul oft à la porte de la
chapelle
dans cette vision du paradis terrestre
puisqu'on mais là loin d'ici là on
pourra y est l'addition pourrait y aller
d'ailleurs jaccottet allez on
il a tourné dans ce paradis terrestre la
longue file des principales
c'est un brin de son âme pour passer à
la télévision
certains ont de quoi pour passer à la
télévision on est dans une émission de
télévision donc qu'elle trouve on le
sait donc ça ça nous touche tous
en fait faut regarder love story nador
midem un départ complètement excusable
jamais valables sarsgaard château story
bien qu est ce qui vous rend rouge de
route
c'est de m'être trompé on fait des
erreurs
y compris dans des papiers on a parlé la
dernière fois on va recommencer
oui mais ça mastery ponts n'a fait le
notaire la dernière fois ci mais voilà
ça c'est bruay en artois le théâtre soit
on arrête d'écrire à la main mais voilà
c'est le problème des épisodes
voilà vous rappeler ceux qui ont raté
les six heures précédant tant pis pour
eux qu'est ce qu'ils vont en bleu de
peur je peux souffler oui dis moi que je
la fonte de la calotte polaire le
réchauffement oui voilà fait merci
faudrait je vous en prie si ça monte
d'un mètre
ouais ça va quand même et dave c'est
terrible nous recevons en bleu peur oui
la fin c'est pas pour demain pas mieux
mais c'est comme j'ai une petite fille
formidable absolument génial
karine mois et demi donc qu'est ce
qu'ils vont en rose de bonheur cette
petite fille sa mère qu'est ce qui vous
fait rire jaune
blake et mortimer voilà c'est un jury
entretien avec alain juppé j'ai gâché
entre casier voilà
et maintenant mesdames messieurs a juste
une question il toujours ligne rames
sont subjectifs ion ouais si frédérique
bedos
mesdames messieurs donc sert je ne
savais pas mais frédéric et la fille
cachée de guy bedos
on connaissait leslie bedos qui fait des
beaux soirs de ciel mon mardi l'émission
de christophe dechavanne est donc là
nous avons frédérique bedos
vous ressemblez pas votre père du tout
non je sais pas ce qu'en fait c'était la
combine vont à trouver pour qu'on ne
sache pas que j'étais sa maîtresse mais
aujourd'hui je lui demande deux voilà
deux ans tout le monde vraiment voilà
bien si tu nous regardes aïeux pas venir
dans cette émission je comprends pas du
tout donc maintenant que ta fille cachée
est venu si tu veux dire c'est la mise à
l'heure et animatrice sur france 2 vous
avez été engagées par dominique cantien
vous avez présenté un hommage à claude
françois avec tout le junior vous avez
écrasé tf1 d'ailleurs l'influencé de
claude françois
j'ai entendu lundi en dépôt de françois
junior est très sous les couleurs sang
et or dominique cantien chercher
quelqu'un
vous dites ça elle cherchait quelqu'un
pour présenter cette émission et vous
dit à la télévision il ya deux types de
femmes
il ya des femmes à poigne comme
christine bravo et les jolies filles
donc vous c'est pas très gentil pour
christine bravo non non il faut ça c'est
une caricature non mais ce que je dis
c'est que c'est vrai qu'en règle
générale on a un peu les femmes qui
dirige vraiment leurs émissions qui ont
le concept même sur leurs visages pas
cécile dumas christine bravo
et puis d'un autre côté il ya celle
qu'on engage plus parce qu'elles sont
jolies et qu'on se dit que ça fait
toujours de l'audience d'être jolie
alors moi je pense que jenny le concept
ni le côté super joli mais les deux noms
mais j'essaye de je m'adapte au concept
original et c'est pas un théâtre qui on
va voir alors vous est présenté avec
jean luc delarue les victoires de la
musique et puis tout seul
nos années 70 alors sur mtv ou présenter
tous les soirs à 21h une émission qui
s'appelle french line donc c'est une
demi heure de musique 100% française sur
mtv voilà c'est de la musique 100%
française mais pas n'importe laquelle on
n'est pas là pour se regarder le nombril
il utilise une chaîne mondiale
donc ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on a choisi
comme angle les français qui s'exporte
la musique internationale donc wire il
ya air quelques personnes
phoenix il y en a tellement il a été
négligent mo johnston bien voilà ce
qu'est le hip hop le rap quand même on
est rentrés dames messieurs pouvez
l'applaudir
des bleus
avec le losc et on vient me voir hier
qu'est-ce qu'elles puissent paul house
au lasso et l'âme
j'apprends qu'on le dimanche après midi
parce qu'il paraît que je vais faire le
dimanche après midi il m'a dit c'est à
pau le mans c'est juste un email alors
vous avez trente ans vous êtes né en
normandie
ça vous avez dit vous appelez bedos
monde sérieux non franchement non non
parce que justement dès que j'arrivais
quelque part on me demandait si c'était
sa fille je disais non et tod termine
fait quoi avec moi serait pas marcher
j'oublie tout de suite votre mère et
normand de votre père haïtien
il est venu ici ça réfugiés politiques
votre père il a aidé partie du temps de
quad duvalier donc j'ai vécu à lille et
pillages de 15 ans est arrivé à paris
bac à 15 ans et là mesdames et messieurs
attention
histoire de l'art à la sorbonne école du
louvre maîtrise en égyptologie la mine
de rien précoce pour l'amour pas trop
précoce vous dit quand j'étais petit
temps je remarquais pas quand on drague
est vrai déjà j'étais super myope et
puis je me suis fait opérer donc ça y
est je vois mais je ne servent pas parce
que c'est une habitude qu'on perd quand
on est myope
donc je croisais les gens déjà je les
voyais pas donc je sais pas si oui et
puis et puis je crois que j'avais la
tête ailleurs quoi j'allais l'été dans
les bouquins j'ai toujours là dedans
et en plus de ça on n'a même pas la
vision de soi même quand on a la niaque
on se regarde dans la glace et
maintenant vous êtes vous vous plaisez
quand même basket c'est que j'ai souvent
dans la journée je perd la mémoire de ce
que je suis ouais si vous voyez ce que
je veux dire
ces intellectuels fed avec c'est pour
cela que je vous ai mis sur un coup là
c'est à vous de vous débrouiller si tu
veux non par les attentions depuis et
alors la preuve que vous remarquez pas
quand on voudra qu'un jour un mec vous
abordent et vous dis comme ça je vais
vous engager pour une chaîne à new york
c'est une chèvre ou évidemment vous
voyez pas qu'il voudra que le mec
et c'était vrai le mec était le
président de la chaîne fashion and
design
il était à paris pour le pour le
tournage de l'it à paris pour tourner un
jeu prêt-à-porter d'altman et c'est
incroyable coup de bol quoi ce soir on
est dans le vrai coup de bol pas vous
soucier du travail et beaucoup de
travail
au croisement de routine quand même bon
et valdes à son casting à prague elle
est engagée elle surtout à paris et vous
voilà le type vous emmène à canal+
m'appelle à 23 ans vous vous retrouvez
donc à new york
et puis vous travailler là bas quelques
temps vous revenez en france 3 yaté
lequan avec les stades de chavannes au
téléachat de m6 s'est déjà moi tu es
vraiment le trou noir dont je garde une
certaine c'est bien en même temps de
passer par là parce que ça m'a montré ce
que c'est quand on est inconnu en france
on a quand même on s'est quand même ne
pourront pas relancer son boulot et
finalement on vous ferme la porte au nez
quoi parce que si vous n'êtes pas copine
avec truc pas la fidh machin moi ou je
ne sais quoi d'autre bah rien vous
n'êtes rien on vous ferme la porte au
nez
vous faites des achats sur m6 vous
qu'êtes spécialistes comme je le dis en
égyptologie un indianisme pas si vous
voyez quand même mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est quand même comme cisma
engagé en me disant bien à temps c'est
juste pour commencer après tu auras une
tourraton émission patati patata pipeau
que dalle et du coup je me retrouve
première pensée à betv
moi je vous dirais alors que chaîne
musicale quand même et pourtant vous
avez le look a travaillé sur m6 moi je
trouve ça moi je trouve que je suis bien
mieux sur des biens là c'est continue
nouveau coup de bol un jour une
conférence de presse des petits vivent
ou tombé sur un mec un peu débraillé
e le type un peu bas ben quoi et puis je
trouve quand même que c'est brenton
scène le patron l'a motivé j'ai vraiment
de la chance voilà mais je c'est vrai
que je suis arrivé en retard donc je
savais pas du tout ce qui est et qui de
quoi ça parle et je vois ce type qui
ressemble à rien moi j'aime bien les
gens qui aiment les gens qui ressemblait
alors il le sait il le sait et ça le
fait marrer ça a vraiment des super cool
et voilà c'est des gens je suis désolé
mais les anglo saxons ça en règle
générale bah ils savent regarder les
gens dès qu'ils ont su vous regardez ses
célèbres
donc voilà donc alors évidemment vous
êtes très ambitieuse un peu comme vous
la trêve vous en voulez un et vous dites
quand on veut faire la télé il faut
savoir où frédéric je vous le dis parce
que si vous savez par ailleurs par
ailleurs l'année prochaine il faut
savoir se blinder l'âme
comment on fait pour se blinder là mais
je pense que c'est même pas seulement si
on veut faire de la télé c'est dès qu'on
vit dans les médias qu'on est un peu
exposés c'est clair que on entend des
choses sur vous on vous tracasse ceci
cela oui il faut se blinder
comment retrouver en photo dans voici
avec votre jules savoir l'amener blindés
bah j'ai eu de la chance c'est que à
part qu'il avait juste une photo avec
les doigts dans le nez ça fait quoi
mais le truc c'est pas ça c'est que par
principe je parle pas forcément de ma
vie privée j'ai pas eu de délit tout ça
on s'en fout et puis c'est vrai que
c'est étonnant on dit tiens on était un
dimanche en train de bruncher y avait un
mec qui était planqué quelque part
bosser un peu strange
on a vu à cette occasion d'ailleurs vous
le dites je suis pas attirée par les
trop beau mec ce ribotti pour le
connaissais très bien on veut pas dire
sont un peu plus grave si on peut le
dire si si parce que maintenant que ça a
été dit est temps de dire ouais bah
ouais maintenant lille a fait toutes les
photos de la tour eiffel au monde l'an
2000 c'est l'ubs lienhard jean-paul
luminaires jean paul lubliner qu'on
connaît bien
vous allez vous y arrivez vous nous
faire choper dans un journal style voici
avec un journal de canal de calais
halak qui avec les gens et qui j'étais
pas du tout c'est des histoires
inventées souvent là quelque part
heureusement là ils sont tombé pile poil
c'est vrai que c'était mon mec j'aurais
très bien pu y avait aucune photo
équivoque ça aurait très bien pu être un
pote évasive là c'est parti
mais voilà qu'elle revient à bouquin
vous serez dans la page livre et puis le
pire le pire de l'histoire si vous avez
été vendus par quelqu'un qui vous
connaît c'est clair rien que ça c'est
terrible c'est salut aux mains des lames
toujours là ça le truc le plus troublant
parce quand j'ai déménagé et pas
longtemps donc c'est quelqu'un qui sait
y mon adresse qui savait qui était mon
mec à quelle heure j'étais là patati
patata
ça c'est troublant maintenant ça veut
dire il faut un petit peu se méfier pas
tout dire le monde m'en faut que je
passe un coup de fil excusez moi bien
alors pour évaluer votre vraie
personnalité on va vous faire une
interview psy vous êtes prête
en attendant le jingle
[Musique]
merci nadine je trouve extraordinaire je
suis le parcours voilà nadine de
rothschild je comprends pourquoi être
non vous à pourquoi ça s'est si bien
passée avec edmond pendant ces trente
sept ans c'est à dire vous êtes la femme
idéale je joue mise en chine et merci
voilà et après des récits des as que
dans soumise une connotation péjorative
que je lis franchement je n'apprécie pas
obéit singes disons frédéric ne vous
mentez pas insultants envers la baronne
du tout bien frédéric vous êtes prête
alors interview psy c'est facile est ce
que vous êtes mytho pas vraiment non
mégalo
pas vraiment non plus paranos parano
quand j'ai un peu bu ou quand j'ai un
peu fumé je vous dis j'aime pas qu'on va
voir vos émissions poser la question
bonjour local banni d'accord d'accord
hervé il faut parler un peu de josé
cabanis on parle jamais de prix renaudot
en 66 né en 1922 à toulouse josé cabanis
l'auteur de l'âge ingrat
voilà c'est vrai nom n'en parle jamais
marre on parle semaine turba pourquoi
hier débours je refuse qu'on parle de ce
grand jeu c'est inquiète je sais pas
vous êtes schizo schizo je pense pas non
bazot meiway à les aimer qu'on vous
fasse mal non j'aime pas je me fais moi
même
ah ouais donc ça suffit toi je voulais
tenter un truc est ce que vous aimez
faire mal c'est un peu sado non pas du
tout non vous êtes homo un peu eva par
rapport à ce qu'on dit vous avez échappé
dans ma main on sait pas je vous en
remercie mille fois oui
non mais moi je vais vous dire moi j'ai
l'impression ça c'est mon avis personnel
mais j'ai l'impression que toutes les
filles sont un peu même celles qui se
lave ou pas ouais je crois que pour un
mec sait plus
mais après l'émission s'est réjoui m
[Musique]
moi je reste tranquille bien continue
n'est pas non c'est pas non est ce que
vous êtes trio ça peut olalalala jamais
dire jamais juge que je le dis en somme
un bébé va-t-il s'en remettre je ne suis
pas sûr parce que par un mot vous iriez
dans des boîtes échangistes tous les
samedis soirs vous aurait répondu quoi
tous les samedis soirs non un samedi sur
deux non même un samedi sur deux samedis
par mois
non je dirai ce une histoire tirée une
expérience de temps en temps why not
pourquoi pas français baghi je te
félicite d'affilée beaucoup mieux que
toi je vais exhibo quelque part on est
un peu puisque on passe à la téloche
enfin vous balader pas à poil devant
votre fenêtre pour le voisin et tout ça
ça vous pouvez passer l'info l'info non
non mais non mais non mais non non non
non non non non vous aimez bien ça mais
vous n'êtes pas d'infos dire j'aime
l'amour mais jules non je parle a pas au
point d'être nymphomane voilà c'est tout
l'air non voilées freiner la nymphomane
qui est en vous voilà est-ce que vous
êtes vibro un vibro de temps en temps un
rôle à la la
est ce que vous êtes porno vous regardez
les cassettes pornos part ça je trouve
ça super bidon naze
ah ben on a vraiment changé je lance un
appel trouver un réalisateur qui sache
faire un film porno bien un truc
qu'excitant sympa vrai je sais pas ce
que ça c'est gros naze quoi des nanas
qui sont là qui gémissent c'est hyper
faux nom on sera l usine on secoure quoi
vraiment je comprends que quelque part
ça excite plus de gens de regarder des
reality truc c'est vrai quelque part
cela ferait un film de marc dorcel vous
choisissez quoi au nom love story c'est
vraiment trop elle se passe pas grand
chose mais je dirais que je suis pas à
la cassette qui s'est vendue sous le
bras de pamela anderson dans un voyage
de jean marie ça doit être sympa ça
voilà je pense que ça donne c'est quand
même plus sympa que virginie pour de
vergy connaît ses amis c'est laetitia là
nous contacter il faut s'intéresser mst
maman c'est que tu tournes
bien bien la question est la plus
importante d'une certaine façon est ce
que vous êtes adamo adamo
non c'est pas vrai c'était avant
[Musique]
et maintenant mesdames messieurs
attention c'est du lourd
on va
[Musique]
voici faste à voici jean philippe lafont
à
poussez-vous mais c'est lui un peu ses
instincts mais attention là c'est autre
chose là à ça va bien vous êtes assis là
ça y est vous êtes ça dit à quoi la
chanson une fesse vous êtes apprécié la
cua 115 kilos là elles peuvent pas le
plus drôle le rsa attention bien que non
ça va très bien aussi
mais le problème avec moi c'est que
quand je fais 125 comme aujourd'hui je
suis aussi l'est et à 80km bien ça le
problème c'est l'ancien joueur de rugby
on va en parler bien sûr vous connaissez
jean philippe lafont
c'est extraordinaire s'il était né vous
savez avec nathalie de ces et roberto
alagna vous êtes aujourd'hui l'un des
rares chanteurs français à poursuivre
une carrière internationale g3 rien pas
beaucoup nathalie de si on l'a eue à
lanières n'a pas encore eu mon à la fin
aujourd'hui on est très flattée que vous
soyez là alors quand on sait comment
votre vie a commencé on trouve
effectivement un petit peu comme on l'a
dit tout à l'heure pour beaucoup de gens
ici un destin absolument incroyable
alors on va d'abord faire la promo et
puis après on va parler de votre vie
vous savez comment on fait monsieur
lafon jeu mais sympa avec lui pour qu'il
le fait
à
et
julie qui fait des bouquins avec juppé
qui nous la joue révolutionnaire bien
alors donc ça c'est un c'est un cd donc
ses fans staff c'est chez philips pour
le centenaire de la mort de verdi avec
l' orchestre révolutionnaire
l'orchestré révolutionnaire et
romantique de sir john eliot gardiner
vous avez chanté récemment cette version
d'ailleurs au châtelet vous avez chanté
à baden baden opre rrom ce à londres
avec ses et il fallait faire c'est vous
avez quand même joué cinquante fois fall
staff et vous dites aujourd'hui j'ai 49
ans j'ai l'âge du rôle mais vous avez
toujours aimé falstaff parce que la
première fois c'est une glande le mois
dernier oui oui car quand vous aviez
quand vous aviez 36 ans la première fois
que vous avez fait face le staff à
l'opéra de lyon on vous disiez je suis
un peu trop jeune pour le rôle on s'est
toujours arrangé mais j'ai le poids à
l'épave ou physique que 115 kg je tiens
à le rappeler jean philippe vous êtes à
125 attention alors en fait valser a
fait beaucoup plus gros que vous et le
soir on vous met un peu que vous faisiez
face à l'élan marc me met carrément faux
ventre
ce qui a fait dire à une de mes filles
je vois pas pourquoi on fait rentrer des
jeunes sympas suffisant pour le rôle
c'est une chambre à air qui a été coulé
sur sur moi et spa et tous les soirs on
me gonfler mes vieux lille à genoux
devant lui la jolie qui s'ouvre dans un
petit tuyau point fort mais parfois
c'était trop gonflé alors elle m'appuyer
5 10 minutes pour me re dégonfler voilà
et ça vous donne l'impression d'être
maigre puisqu'il faut grossir pour faire
le rôle donc c'est à dire quand je
redeviens comme maintenant je suis ravie
voir ces trafiquants et la barbe
même avec mike betts vous continuer à
porter la barbe de farfalles staff s'est
passé pas sûr c'est encore décidé c'est
la monnaie n'est pas n'est pas sûr de ce
qui va se passer
peut-être tout ça coupait c'est arriva
de barbares mais moi j'aime bien cela
vous dit on chez de galles il faut
jamais avoir la même mais vous dites je
suis une feuille blanche je suis à la
disposition du metteur en scène et
souffre une fois amsterdam l'histoire à
la damnation de faust est pas aussi main
mais demandez de caresser le sexe du
ténor joyeux pas je voyais pas tellement
les bananiers pas la nécessité à ce
moment là si je la répète t il voulu
faire éduquer et c'est le sexe pendant
voici des roses de fautes et là quand
j'ai dit non le lhc peut être un peu
hésité gg je montrais un petit peu le
geste même si vous voulez vraiment que
ça soit très très très très près vous
n'êtes pas aux mots du tout a priori
nommé va dire aussi si je pourrais être
homosexuel avec avec un seul que j'ai
rencontré dans ma vie
michael jordan 1 j'ai été très
impressionné par ce type là j'étais à
chicago il ya quelques années j'ai vu
cet homme jure j'ai vu un demi dieu voit
la jeune fille d'une grande élégance
d'une grande correction génial sur l'un
des spurs sur le parquet
j'ai vu quelqu'un que j'avais jamais vu
équipé de la fin quand même je remarque
c'est l'émission de toutes les
révélations
je veux dire il va falloir vous mettre à
table
alors on passe à votre histoire qui est
incroyable vous êtes né en 1951 à
toulouse dans une famille c'est modeste
votre père était employé agents de l'edf
est effectivement dès l'âge de 10 ans
votre père vous amène à l'opéra en faux
capitole pouvoir des opérettes et vous
voyez la veuve joyeuse m'en faire votre
père surtout il ya les pour les filles
vous absolument c'était pour voir les
jambes des filles quelques airs qu'ils
pouvaient siffloter à la sortie un mais
bon c'était plus pour l'ambiance car
c'est sûr que l'opérette un côté un peu
plus un peu plus entre guillemets
sympathie au niveau des formes d des
jeunes femmes aux des femmes taux courts
qui sont sur la scène que chez nous ça
s'améliore alors je revois de cesser un
jour vous allez voir il votre père la
chaste suzanne donc c'est comme vous
dites une d'yvette j'adore cette
expression une d'yvette marseillaise
l'univers est donc vous dit à la sortie
au papa je la trouve très belle cette
dame elle est à moitié nue et votre père
vous réponds moi aussi mon fils c'est
pour elle que je suis venu ici
c'était très clair la divette
marseillais se plaisait aux deux alors
l'époque vous jouer au rugby
alors voilà qu'alors que vous avez en
comprend au stade toulousain
quelques ares urbains et alors après la
victoire vous chantez dans les
vestiaires et là un jour un prof
d'anglais de sainte barbe le collège
vous étiez henry agnel ex-chanteur très
belle voix d un très belle voix de
baryton futur directeur de la scène au
capitole vous entend chanter et dit il a
une voix extraordinaire c'est à dire
qu'ils jouent au rugby
il est en effet ce tiers qui chantent
pour la victoire ce type arié jouent
chantent et même sur le terrain je me
souviens exemple on était en touche ce
pas un pour narguer un peu les
adversaires je leur chante est carrément
sentiers quoique l on s'était à l'époque
plutôt du style mariano en effet devoir
non fait pas plaisir faites-moi la belle
de cadix
c'est parti
je ne suis pas mal teaser d'âge
je suis pas mal content et il n'est pas
le premier rugbyman a chanté à bombay il
y avait jean pierre françois jetté sur
20 bah oui c'est mon répertoire na waie
c'est un footballeur jean pierre
françois
merci l'oreillette
m
il loge
bien alors là vous rentrez au
conservatoire de toulouse et le jour de
l'épreuve vous arrive est très sûr de
vous un parce que avant même d'avoir
appris à y mettre une note en place vous
pensiez déjà que j'ai tjrs et le baryton
du siècle grande confiance en bougie
nombreuses avec la toute façon un et
alors là que ça s'est passé
ce concours pour entendre des moments
passagers est il vraiment c'était très
long parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
monde devant moi et je dis à tous ces
gens sont mauvais
qu'est ce qu'ils sont venus faire alors
j'ai audition comme ça a été mon tour
j'ai chanté un air de lacq mais je me
souviens
et comme je suis arrivé au premier
couplet à la note à note aiguë je les
canarder comme même si ce n'est pas
possible c'est fait comme on dit chez
nous en paix alors j'ai pris mes
lunettes j'avais des grosses lunettes en
écaille
je les ai prises un petit peu furieux en
me disant oh deuxième couplet ils
entendent différences qui vont entendre
une deuxième coupe et ça a été pire
ça a été alors c'est cassé mais d'une
rivale de ça et ils ont été ravis de ce
geste ou de la personnalité de saison
quand même pris peut-être quelque chose
à faire là oui voilà alors le problème
que vous aviez à l'époque si vous saviez
pas lire la musique c'est à dire que
quand vous voyez des notes sur une
partition il pensait que c'est des
petites piques parents et contrôlez pas
non mais c'est vrai mais il faut lire ça
quand y'en a un pays pensait que ça veut
dire puissant lorsque leurs pianos donc
ré du mal au début un oui ah oui
beaucoup
heureusement qu'il y de nice duplex que
des gens que beaucoup de patients
cerleau si des gens comme beaucoup
beaucoup de façons ça vénus du plach
s'ils existent toujours
surtout me fait toujours travailler et
vivre c'est presque 30 ans et
qui ne me passe rien mais l'icann à
plusieurs scandales mais vous vous
continuez la ram j'ai toujours besoin de
plus en plus surtout que mon répertoire
évolue et on a toujours besoin d'une
oreille
l'absolu en face de soi parce qu'on fait
on fait des bêtises pour me donne toute
manière de prouver sur nos métiers il
faut que quelqu'un soit là pour vous
rattraper parfois alors vous casser le
jeu nous donc ça arrête le sport vous
rentrez au conservatoire de lyon puis au
conservatoire de paris
et aujourd'hui alors effectivement vous
êtes mondialement célèbres comme jeudi
en commençant dans des rôles latin et
vous allez vers des rôles vers wagner
disons les choses un peu plus en plus
depuis deux puis trois zones une
évolution qui bon je garde les les rôles
dramatiques qui tannait français mais il
ya une évolution qui se fait vers un
répertoire allemand donc strauss richard
chance et wagner et à trois ans j'ai eu
la chance de le bonheur d'être pris à
bail ruyt d'oublier cette année
d'ailleurs pour le lohengrin et y avait
40 ans le choc de facilité pour aller
loin et quand même très très ravi c'est
vrai que ma sensibilité la couleur de la
voix le mot l'émotion se fait que je
vais plutôt dense dans cette direction
là vous dit tu vas retrouver le sens de
vie que je crois avoir perdu aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que finalement avec les
rôles latin vous tourner un peu en rond
oui je trouve je trouve qu'il y a moins
de ces sur laon pour un toulousain parce
que je suis vraiment de l'insula brin
toutes les qualités et les défauts de
des gens du sud mais dans le jeu ne
trouve pas je ne trouve plus où je n'ai
pas vraiment de trouver l'émotion dans
la musique italienne voir française
émotion que j'ai vraiment quand je
chante le mot allemand je trouve que il
ya une résonance dans dans le mot
allemand lui même et dans la musique de
wagner par exemple qui fait que je suis
plus nourris que dans notre forme un
nouveau territoire pour vous alors pour
finir moi je vais vous raconter
l'anecdote que que vous connaissez pas
ce que les historiens c'est quand votre
père vient à paris pour voir pdac me
disant de raconter là parce que ça
résume t le nombre de vies appelle les
associations élisée je crois en tes aux
champs-elysées 185 et pelléas et
mélisande est un opéra qui
malheureusement ne plaît pas beaucoup et
surtout surtout quand on le voit pour la
première fois est assez pour lui la
première fois est ce cet après midi là
c'est un dimanche après-midi c'était la
finale stade toulousain toulon de rugby
et mon père qui n'émet encore une fois
que tu vraiment que l'opérette il faut
bien le dire de but si ce n'est pas son
fort vraiment et ils avaient et je ne le
savaient pas ils avaient mis une petite
oreille oreillettes et l'écouté la
finale et coûtait rien pendant moi je
chante terre et que nous chantions le
pédiatre sur la scène et alors il arrive
à la fin dans ma loge il était il avait
l'air fatigué et il m'a dit ça a été dur
tu sais alors jeune et bon c'est vrai
que ça lui a pas plu elle les a cessé
les ans est passé par il est venu parce
que je suis au fils qui était en face de
lui ça a été dur est avancé se sentent
pas plus mais non ça a été très dur on a
gagné mais alors pour difficile
la loire
on va me reposer là vous allez faire
d'interview innover répondre par oui ou
par non ça n'a pas beaucoup fatigué vous
savez que en êtes vous
m
tigana
jean galle fait pas la gauche
révolutionnaire depuis la gauche
révolutionnaire beigbeder julie on a
fait mai 68 ans est d'accord j'avais
trois ans et alors dans mes bras
jean-philippe si vous trompiez votre
femme vous lui diriez nadine medic lui
nadine avoue sa mère nana vous ai jamais
défini carte les verts mais non c'est
ridicule quand vous avez vous explique
quand vous avez quand vous à vous et à
votre femme vous êtes comme un petit
garçon qui veut se faire pardonner par
sa maman
c'est un peu ridicule et la femme et ne
vous pardonnera jamais paru lundi n'a
absolument voilà oui d'autant plus qu'on
n'a rien à avouer c'est mon pote bien
donc vous vous ne diriez vous devez
absolument pas quelqu'un qui vous aiment
pas qui vous le fait savoir ça vous vexe
non y at il encore un fantasme que vous
n'avez pas réalisé
joker que jordan aller sur table mois la
boue est-ce que vous quitteriez tout
pour grand amour et je dis non non parce
que je les ai déjà trouvé donc ça y est
c'est fait à ces faits vous savez que
c'est pour toujours maintenant ah oui je
crois j'ai mis du temps le ya plus de
cinq ans il ya 12 ans la et la passion
physique continue à l'est elle elle est
plus forte
bravo bravo bravo j'ai ma conseillère
maintenant suivre
moi je ne fais plus un rat son téléphone
c'est beaucoup mieux qu'à 12h à rennes
est ce que vous feriez un film porno
pour un million de francs dont 2
millions dont trois millions quatre
meilleurs du tout 10 millions dont et
gagne bien sa vie
vu le monsieur est bas une porno pour un
million deux millions hamad a refusé
kubrick est là parce qu'elle était à
poil un mois pour 1 franc
frédéric je pose pas la question vous
d'accord non trois noms n'ont pas les
2,4 millions 5 millions non non mais
c'est il faut 14 1 milliards de
milliards de milliards je préfère je
préfère l'histoire de propositions
indécentes avec robert redford pas oui
bah oui oui ça se fait mais les nuls
parce que robert cassang ce film est
ridicule cette opérette soit 0 feront
tout le monde l'aurait faire est ce que
vous vous aimez passer dans leur dire
oui ou non
est ce que vous nous aimez oui oui
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez la voir
bon
john
messieurs nous arrivons dans la classe
final cette émission leblanc thèse a
consacré ce soir au cinéma festival de
cannes oblige et j'accueille pour
arbitrer de blind test majeur a fait
déborder
je
beaucoup davantage être animateur de
télévision
je m'aperçois je m'en aperçois ce soir
bien alors philippe comment ça va très
bien n'oublions surtout pas s'y lie à
soufflage et a pas très bien si à
soufflage la paire d'as bien donc je les
attendais donc s'appeler comment thierry
je vous oublier et vous et s'il a lieu
bonsoir
accepteriez de faire un film porno ouah
bien et j'ai un truc pour ça
je sais les enfants vous voulez mais je
pense beaucoup à vous en ce moment bien
alors on va y aller donc si alors s'y
attendait attention précision de le dire
le titre du film
voilà c'est clair malgré tout le respect
que je vous dois joue qui rit les
clappes ouais c'est le festival de
cannes way fait voir un gars comme
classe
ah oui quand les lunettes pour les stars
quand j'ai eu la peau les stars didier
le vide hier attention première musique
indiana jones et les aventuriers de
l'arche perdue
le ghana
pénalité
bien attention ça c'est plus de notre
époque à nous on a dîné seul
[Applaudissements]
il a fallu aller
oui
[Applaudissements]
louise prix est non mais tu veux me
faire gagner pour que j'aurai sur paris
première c'est ça non c'est pas ça que
je vous ai déjà dit frédéric que vous
avez une grande culture musicale pour un
garçon de votre âge parce qu'il n'a que
35 en patois je suis pas du tout
dangereux lâchers d'eau sur vos copines
moi j'y suis bien en continu
oh la la
la fri
l'ico
aïe robert wise
oui mais
non
bien que serge july commence par dit le
nom du réalisateur avant dire le titre
du film
et voilà c'est sa libération au tournage
la date de tournage de tous il y avait
au catherine ce que ce que serait qu'ils
en pensent
alors continue au sein
attention attention il ya eu souffla
s'il ya un soufflage
attendez si un soufflage à perdre à un
scandale à brix
burberry
non
m
eh ben c'est quand même intervenir
excréments pas dite parp auraient-ils a
dit coco
je n'ai fait elle était dans leur
mission c'est moi qui les fais ces
vendeurs bras bien sûr bien sûr
non c'est vrai c'est pas très
reconnaissants il va te permettre bien 7
steve owens
[Applaudissements]
je vous soupçonne d'avoir des relations
avec ma femme qui fait le buzz à une
thèse en franchement c'est toujours est
il
c'est trop facile le purple rain austin
powers excusez moi mais je sais que les
gens chez eux ça fait une heure qu'ils
ont tout compris
donc on est un 5 pour les lunettes bien
je suis désolé pour les clubs
comment marche le clap les personnes
n'ont rien moi si je regarde beaucoup
beaucoup le club en continu le tisot
viser le titre
[Musique]
libre
pierrot monde
5 à 2 2 pour les claques évidemment en
continu une petite ville
et donc ça fait quand même 3 500 train
de remonter les clappes désolé beigbeder
laffont l'un d'eux dos là attention
attention bravo eva ohlala
pourquoi
de vous inviter à cordes et serge july
va faire un livre avec edouard balladur
la prochaine fois dit non non ah bon
c'est fini la droite bien alors on
continue
le titre du ville ohlala
soufflage père john baird a
oh
[Musique]
si jacques 4 grâce à nadine de
rothschild les clappes remonte à 4 je
vais faire animateur de jeu j'adore
ben moi je fais chier à faire des
interviews toute ma vie là j'adore faire
ça
s'il ya soufflage ya paire d'as ils ont
même adressé la direction de france 2
qui fait une part je suis d'accord bien
on continue le titre du film
à la haye
dia ba oui jean philippe lafont bravo
alors vraiment extraordinaire alors
vraiment on est capable de chanter
macbett c'est de reconnaître la guerre
des étoiles n'y a pas beaucoup plus si
c'est entre quatre yeux c'est bien une
pochette de jani lane comme ça et bien
alors continue rien c'est vous
sinon je donnais mes commandes valident
connaissez doit-il pas ce qu'il m'a dit
qu'on est nous étions de la même époque
alors vous voyez nous sommes de la
minute suivante comment vous allez hop
événements j'ai avec moi vous avez fait
un gros travail ce soir la libre alors
on continue 14
si tu fais psychose voilà preneur
je ne sais pas
je vous demande de vous
jamais pas fini
mais pas fini ce n'est pas fini de faire
leur ballet tout à fait trop de pression
bon alors 8 pour les lunettes noires 5
pour les clapiers vous connaissez la
règle du jeu
il ya maintenant le super banco et celui
qui trouve l'équipe qui trouve le super
banco à gagner je sais c'est injuste
mais la vie est injuste avec une fille
et deux nuls
la ville rose une attention
hier
g
le public
[Musique]
srinivasan
gfr
[Musique]
à la vie
délicate à méo et juliette à lomé c'est
la version
je vais demander à ripley parce qu'il
paraît qu'ils auraient eu tricherie à
on rigole on me dit en régie qui aurait
eu tricherie que vous auriez souffle et
nadine de rothschild où tu vas c'est
roméo + juliette le film de l'urban baz
luhrmann qui qui vient de faire un film
à cannes qui vient de faire moulin rouge
à cannes dai a été obligé juin
je viens de vous taperez pleine
[Musique]
attention
non je vois que philippe corti et
accompagner qui se ressemble s'assemble
c'est tout ce que je dirai je termine
maintenant non
il va y avoir maintenant il va y avoir
simplement se mettre très simple c'est
que frédérique bedos eva herzigova vous
allez faire le jeu du home armes et à
ben oui
siri gallas est bien jeune âge là là
alagi juin
l'âge venant vraiment nous arrêter parce
que j'ai joué au mans 2e set agl pas le
jeu du homard c'est très influent vous
comprenez il faut tomber en même temps
que le homard et effectivement c'est
très compliqué de tomber exactement même
temps et s'il faut on fera un replay
quand le homard tombe vous êtes tombé en
même temps que lui attention
stationnaire
m
mais bon
en régie qui a gagné jeudi aux mains
pardon
à
bravo
ramon
et voilà
félicité pour sa victoire bravo c'est
formidable
du côté des gagnants
de ça
des citations bactéries
voilà c'était tout moment par l'émission
pas comme les autres lambert puis sexe
magouille et culture générale de laurent
baffie avec laurent baffie pascal sellem
mas de morales
russo géraldine blé guirao
ronaldinho la saison prochaine au psg
millions
frédéric ii
bien
en liquidation j'ai résistance des nuls
mais les ghanéens mon cabinet son schéma
c'est l'édition 2 l'amour dieu présent
c'est voler
mission de mémoire d'un jeune homme
dérangé chez folio et merci
à nadine de rothschild voilà l'amour est
une affaire de famille chez rona
serge
entre le cas dieu chez grasset entretien
avec alain juppé mais là messieurs
on joue tous les soirs l'intérieur sur
mtv et sur france 2 pour des soirées
spéciales
jean-philippe la pente
une femme staff verdi et bientôt macbeth
de pierre de la monnaie à bruxelles et
bientôt l'eau aniline au festival vo
voilà c'est désolant par l'émission pas
comme les autres rendez vous samedi
prochain
[Musique]
mais non
non
[Musique]
pas
m
tu
[Musique]
elle
non
bon
quelle est la même
[Musique]
les
m
ans
[Musique]
des jumeaux
là
[Musique]